e
e e
like a few announcements first here um
all of you have if you've been um kind
of paying attention to what's going on
in the Senate just to give you kind of a
brief update and representative Sullivan
you feel free to to add a few things
um I received an email I guess from uh
representative of wolf yesterday that
our bill regarding um firefighters on
the way to a call um the way we amended
that um the Senate has app approved it
out of committee 5 to zero and it looks
like it's going to be on the consent
agenda so it's okay the bill
regarding um UTI being able to utilize U
medical marijuana as a
acceptable um I don't want to say
condition what is acceptable uh form of
treatment um there has been a
considerable amount of push back uh by
law enforcement uh in the Senate I did
speak to the lobbyists for law
enforcement yesterday and they don't
know what the Senate is going to do with
it um so um that that's up in the air uh
representative kahill and I yesterday
spoke on um H Bill 1178 regarding um
uh receipt of uh vacation time and and
such and
uh they were in the middle now they have
a lot of things to look at uh
representative K did a good job
presenting his case I I I uh presented
my two cents and and we gave them an
amendment and uh whether they're going
to whether they do these things or have
a subcommittee I'm waiting to talk to
the chairman to see where he wants to go
with that
um I think we came to consensus that two
of the three things things that that
that representative kill and I agree on
they may accept so we we'll wait and see
how that goes so I don't know I have not
heard of any games being played with any
of our bills so I don't know um but um
we we will wait and see uh unfortunately
the Senate
uh very
surprisingly um did not uh pass the
unemployment Securities increase in
benefits bill
and I think the the I was told this
isn't private information I was told by
the uh the Department of Employment
Securities that they didn't think that
the the senator presented really tried
very hard to to try to get it through it
really wasn't any discussion uh I don't
know what went on over there I'm still
trying to find out but I'm probably
going to have one of these bills be a uh
study committee excuse me not a sub
study committee a subcommittee so we can
work on uh representative McKenzie's
Bill and how we we put it on there's
certain rules we're trying to get
answers
to things that I've never had happen
before amending a non a bill with a no
Financial um note with one that might
have a financial note although we don't
think this one really deserves a
financial note so we're waiting to see
what the clerk says about this but I am
going to have a um a um subcommittee on
one of these
probably
um
330 um because it deals with the same
same uh
RSA so those are only things that I have
do anyone have any questions for me
before we get
started okay represent alalani if you
wouldn't mind just
taking few notes if we need to do we
have the packet
and I'm going to get started with uh
Senate Bill 588 Jenny Horgan on behalf
of Senator Lou delis Sandro
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Johnny Horan I am the policy director
for the Senate Democratic caucus Senator
dandro is deeply apologetic that he
could not be here today he is over stuck
in Committee in the Senate so he did ask
me to to bring forward this bill on his
behalf um Senate Bill 588 is relative to
employer notice of veterans benefits and
services the bill directs the Labor
Commissioner in consultation with the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs to create and distribute a
veterans benefits Services poster for
employers to display in the workplace so
the intent of this bill is to ensure
that our veterans are able to be aware
of all the services that they are
entitled to Senator delandra was very
happy to bring forward this piece of
legislation on behalf of our veterans I
am happy to run really quickly through
the bill it's fairly straightforward as
I said it simply directs the Labor
Commissioner to work in consultation to
develop this poster and the benefits
that will be required to be listed on it
include contact and website information
for the New Hampshire Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
information about substance abuse and
mental health treatment resources
educational Workforce and training
resources resources for tax benefit
information information about obtaining
a veterans indicator on a state's
driver's license or non- driver picture
identification card information about
eligibility for unemployment insurance
benefits under state or federal law
legal resources and contact information
for the United The United State's
Department of Veterans Affairs Veterans
Crisis Line um according to the fiscal
note that the department provided the
minimal there would be minimal cost to
implement this poster and to follow
through with ensuring that our veterans
are aware of their benefits that they
are eligible for you know the state of
New Hampshire has thousands of veterans
and Senator delis Sandra wants to make
sure that they are aware of all those
benefits that they are eligible for I am
certainly happy to take any questions
back to the senator I've got my my
notepad and paper but I also know that
there are a number of other individuals
here to testify on the bill so happy to
take any questions at this
point thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions representative McKenzie
I completely support the bill let me
just say that up front I just want to
make sure that um and this is a issue
that been circulating this committee and
I think we have a bill working on it
deals with remote workers to make sure
that remote workers are given this uh
this information as well uh there were
14% of the jobs posted in New Hampshire
recently were remote work and there was
some concern I have about whether or not
the information that the Department
already has the responsibility to to
transmit this information to workers is
uh is going through so I just want to
make sure we get that no I think that's
a really great question it's a really
interesting proposal I'm happy to take
it back to the senator and see if he
would have any concerns about
that representative
St um in looking over the um uh the
materials um from the from the Senate um
I saw that someone from the Department
of Labor said it would also be feasible
to do this via email did I get that
correct I cannot speak to that I was not
in the hearing but I am guessing the
department is the department is not here
but we will make sure that we um reach
out to the department so they they are
here the other side of me so I'm sure
they would be able to offer that
information thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony
Tracy
gaglardi oh all righty my name is Tracy
Gagliardi and I'm here to represent the
United Steel Workers Union and I'm also
here as Tech Sergeant gagliotti with the
United States Air Force 102nd Security
Forces Squadron and I am also a resident
of New Hampshire I come from a military
family my dad was a marine my brother
Army my son is a marine and currently I
am serving at the Air Force National
Guard so when this bill was presented it
h home my dad had struggled with
finances PTSD from Vietnam in his health
over the years before he passed in
2019 he was old school no idea who to
talk to what numbers to call and what he
was entitled to this bill would
certainly help his generation and the
generation to follow just all you have
to do is scan the QR code on the the
sheet
provided everything you need will be
right there in front of you my dad being
the older generation had no idea what
his benefits were or what he was
entitled to when he passed my mom had no
idea what she was entitled to and to me
that isn't fair a man who serves 17
years in the military deserves to know
what his benefit benefits are having
this posting makes it easier for our
service members past present and future
let's be honest we are in an era where
conflict is
inevitable we are sending our brothers
and sisters Sons daughters to fight for
this country let's make it easy for them
to transition back into civilian life
make it easier for them to get the
benefits they are entitled to and what
they fought for coming home from
deployment or War isn't easy transition
for most seeing things that the average
person doesn't see or doing things the
average person and doesn't do makes it a
hard transition back into the civilian
lifestyle when our troops raise their
right hand and take that oath of
enlistment right there they lose their
freedom whether it be 4 years 6 years or
30 more they sacrifice their entire life
family holidays birthdays graduations
weddings births the list goes on they
sacrifice everything they protect
everything to protect this country the
least we can do is put a simple posting
up so they can easily access the help
that they need thank you
thank you are there any
questions seean thank you very much your
testimony right now um loo has do you
want
Tok
you next I'm going to call Kevin Grady
State veterans advisory
committee
welcome thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a 5
year veteran of our air force and I'm a
25- year resident of the town of hookit
New Hampshire today I'm representing the
20 member organization of the state
veterans advisory committee and to be
honest yours is a committee that I don't
see very often so I'd like to take just
a second and give an idea what we do and
then I'm I'm going to tell you that we
fully support this bill we're made up of
20 veteran organizations names that
would be familiar to you things like the
the American Legion the Veterans of
Foreign Wars I personally represent the
air and space forces Association
we have a legislative committee that
looks at bills and then the ones that
have veteran impact I come up and
testify in the public hearing what we
think of these bills we wholeheartedly
support this legislation um because with
the Advent of the PCT act there are now
a lot more veterans walking around there
that are entitled to services that maybe
they don't know that they're entitled to
now so this is a great thing for that we
also like the fact that that because
we're taxpayers too uh this bill doesn't
doesn't look like it's going to cost a
lot of money to move through and and the
last part of this thing is if you look
at the list of people that support this
bill it has strong bipartisan support
across the board and we always are are
happy to get behind a bill like that the
last thing that I want to leave you with
and you're I know you're going to hear
that a lot of people do support this
legislation is we are a resource the
state better advisory committee is a
resource you can use if you're going to
put together a bill that has better
impact come see us we'll help you with
the language and we'll make sure that
the bill says exactly what it is that
you wanted to say and subject to your
question sir that's all I wanted to tell
you this
morning any questions sitting down thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you
sir Paul
morresy usw
good morning ladies and gentlemen of the
New Hampshire house thank you for
allowing me to speak on behalf of SB 588
my name is Paul morenzi I'm a proud
member of United Steel Workers and a
veteran of the US Army Army Reserve I
serve for a total of 12 Years while
serving in the military your pay is not
great but you earn many worthwhile
benefits these benefits are paid for by
the us taxpayers the money is allotted
to the different programs to serve the
veteran Community if the program is not
used its funding is reduced the cut the
reason this happens is to some to some
programs is because either the veterans
don't know about the program or can't
figure out how or where to get the
information to access it at the time
when military members are rsing from
their service whether it's from a state
side foreign or combat deployment you
have mountains of paperwork and files to
go over pay files insurance health forms
gear turnning paperwork and also the
information about different benefits you
have earned this information can be
overwhelming for some and others are
only half listening because they're
young in the best shape of their lives
and they feel Invincible they're not
thinking about health and other benefits
they're more concerned with getting home
to their significant others families
friends and going out to have a beer at
the local pub with their buddies But as
time goes on they get married have
children grow older and they may develop
health issues employment issues or need
legal help the this is when they need
some of those benefits they earned they
don't always remember how or where to
find access to them for veterans who may
be struggling with physical and mental
health issues knowing where to get this
help is extremely important and in some
cases may be a life or death situation
also there's many scams out there that
prey on Veterans so it's important that
they're able to get legitimate
information that is why SB 588 is so
important these postings hanging in the
workplace will list and steer veterans
and their families to legitimate
websites and contacts to get the
information to help by having it posted
in the workplace it will be there to
help the people who need it this is why
I'm asking you to support what I
consider a no-brainer of a bill it is a
bill that will have minimal cost and
will have the ability to help so many
right now this veterans information
poster is being discussed in a bunch of
States I personally hope it becomes a
national law because it's that important
to help the veterans who need the help
Madam cler a
t very well spoken I'm wondering since
your testimony is written if we could
have a copy for sure
posterity not a problem at all thank you
I'm sorry David um Dell
[Music]
Johnson everybody gets it wrong
so all right good morning everybody I
would like to thank the committee for
allowing me to speak in support of SB
relative to employer notice of veterans
benefits and
services my name is Dave doas solar and
I am member of the US W and I reside in
Derry New
Hampshire if SB 588 were to become law
the state of New Hampshire would then
create a posting of veterans Benefit
services and crisis hotline
numbers this posting would then be added
to the mandatory post that are attached
to all employer bulletin boards the
minimum wage boards I call them we feel
that this is a great way for our vets in
the workplace to access all the
important benefits and services that are
there for them and that they are
entitled to the United Ste workers
started this campaign policy last year
and the goal is to have this veterans
posted on employer Bolen boards in all
50 states and
territories the state of New York was
the first to pass this veterans bill and
I believe that there are seven other
states that have passed some sort of
version of the bill in one form or
another we certainly love the state of
New Hampshire to be added to that list I
passed out an example of the post that
the state of New York came up with so
you would have an idea of what sb8 588
is trying to accomplish we feel that
this is a simple but important bill and
urg US committee to vote ought to pass
and send it to the house floor thank you
once again for your
time any no question oh M clerk I see
that your remarks are written and if you
wouldn't mind please submitting them
also for pro pro I can't say the word
all of a sudden I have it on my phone
keep I'll email it thank you so
much
poity um last card on John
garan Department of
Labor good morning everyone John garrian
I'm general counsel for the Department
of Labor um to get to representative
stab and representative McKenzie's
question first about um Can these people
provide electronically the answer is yes
um employers these days can provide
these electronically um there's no
specific format for that but so long as
the employees all have ready access to
this poster as well as the other U
mandatory posters that are required um
beyond that though the the department
has carefully reviewed this bill we have
no concerns about carrying out the
provisions of this bill but I'm happy to
take any questions that the committee
may
have any questions for represent bani
thank you Mr chairman um how is this
going to be enforced in a uh employer by
employer basis if the employer does not
have any employees is this still going
to be mandatory is there will there be a
fine if this is not hung up with the
mandatory postings is it going to be
added to the
mandatory poster that we have um down
the road will it be how are we going to
make sure that this is available to
everyone so if it's not hanging up and
the employer doesn't know about if the
employeer doesn't have employees is he
still going to
be subject to further scrutiny yeah
excellent question so the the way this
uh the other poster law is or those laws
are enforced now is if our inspectors go
out and notice that they're not posted
or if we receive a complaint that the
posters aren't there and there are six
other posters that are required um we
usually engag in in An Education First
strategy um to make sure that they have
the poster and that they can provide it
um under our enforcement law for this
provision which would be
27311 um a violation of this would be a
warning first um any subsequent
violations could be punishable by a
$2,500 or up to a $2,500 civil penalty
um but generally speaking these issues
don't for the posters don't come up that
often it's not a prevalent um complaint
that we receive nor is it a a common
source of our enforcement
actions so if this wasn't posted uh
would there be a reason to have a to go
into an employer and look for other
issues as well would this be a way
into it could be I mean like any
complaint we receive about employers it
could be um but we would likely if if
this were the sole thing we received a
call on I I imagine we would likely
engage first on a telephonic call and
and an education to make sure that they
knew about it and they knew where to
find it and they knew that it had to be
posted thank you thank you thank you Mr
chair representative kale thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question isn't it isn't it
true that uh fines are often drastically
reduced by the department uh if if it
were to be a and I and I do I do doubt
that an inspector would be called in
because that poster is missing or would
not just bring a poster along and say
here would you please hang this up but
in the event that there was a fine as
there are for other violations isn't
that the standard practice of the
department to negotiate that down in
exchange for
compliance that is a very common
practice and again it there wouldn't be
there legally speaking there couldn't be
a fine the first time around uh the way
the laws are in for this particular
violation it would have to be a warning
even if action were taken the fines
would only come into play if there were
subsequent or recurring violations but
the fine would be up to $2500 it doesn't
have to be there's no minimum of $2500
and those findes usually aren't aren't
that thank
you cworth thank you Mr chairman um
something you said sparked a question
about the Department of Labor and the
estimate of the the minimal cost of this
the language of the bill says shall
create and distribute and I'm wondering
does that mean a physical distribution
or what what does that mean to the
department those yeah excellent question
um we provide copies of the posters
electronically um they're not they're
all 8 and 1 half by 11 black and white
printed sheets they're not massive large
color glossy things they're not they're
not pretty that way they're just they're
straightforward into the point so um we
always direct uh employers to our
website that has those on it for them to
print out um If an employer ever
couldn't print one out or needed a
physical copy I'm sure we would take
care of that for them and and provide
that thank
you represent
McKenzie have to keep reminding me turn
probably getting old let me uh let me
ask you the you made a statement that it
generally is not come up as an issue or
a problem do you ever audit any of this
would you ever take a look at and say
okay we we going to take 25 different
businesses and see what their policy is
relative to to transmitting this stuff
electronically because this is a new
wave this is a new situation we're
getting into with the remote workers and
so I was somewhat of a concerned that a
lot of legislation that is uh embraced
in that those notices uh it's important
and people don't know much about the
notices and they probably don't know a
whole heck of a lot about the
protections that are built into those
and how those came to be so so I'd be
interested to know if you ever audited
any of that stuff so I'm not aware of
that ever occurring like that again
usually the posters um any sort of
enforcement on those usually comes up if
the inspector is responding to another
complaint uh at a workplace and just
while there is you know asking you know
where your where are your mandatory
posters where they where they posted um
so I'm not aware of an audit happening
like that um I'm not sure the department
would engage in such an audit just for
just for the posters but I can I can
certainly certainly ask but I'm not
aware of that ever
happening all
it see any other questions thank you
very much thank you I have no other uh
people signed up to present is there
anyone else who has not set a card who
would like
to okay so I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 588
Brian would you take this
hearing we need to open those windows or
does that just
mean oh shoot cuz it's kind of hot in
here yeah I was I want to take my new
jacket pardon I was having trouble
hearing the people speak because of the
rack right we're about to present
Andy thank
you and that's
one y
i are you doing this one I am yes um
just got something from Senator Waters
you can't read here and ask to have this
red
so
okay want to
spread uh
let's see I'll have you go right after
it's
introduced um you
want since there's nobody here I know
I'll just I'll just
have the chairman had to step out to
present an another committee so I will
um chair this hearing and we'll begin
uh with a presentation by the sponsor uh
Senator Bill Ganon thank you very much
uh I am Senator Bill Ganon I represent
District 23 towards the Sea Coast um and
I'm going to mostly talk to you but I'll
keep my Administrative Assistant who
it's her day today if you any of you
have administrative assistance make sure
you get them something today um so I'll
make her happy and read you a couple
sentences and then I'll just start
talking uh thank you Mr President I move
I'm sorry I'm back from my Senate days
this bill is going to clarify the
employment status for University
students who are working in educational
programs by amending the definition of
employee in the labor statutes resident
assistants play a vital role in
residential life programs at higher
education institutions for over a 100
years they have not been viewed as
traditional employees if they were
reclassified as employees their hours
would be tracked and their wages would
be taxable this fundamentally changed
the programs and the universities could
decide to move away from offering Free
Housing so let me tell you personally
this affects me I was um it's way too
long ago when was 84 so I'm like 40
years out of um being an Raa at Dominic
Hall and by when I was there I learned a
lot I learned to it was like a big
brother role in many ways um you were
there for advice uh you were there if
there was a problem um anyone who went
to St ansem knows Dominic was the Hockey
Hall so we had some problems up there
but you learned to deal with people you
learned leadership skills who learned
organizational skills and um helped me a
lot in my first few jobs I have three
children now who are either just
finishing College um I've won Billy's at
um finishing up at 10 he really got into
higher educational academic areas
because he was an RA At Con College led
him to his first job um now he's going
to start a doctoral program there thank
God they're free because I couldn't
afford them um and I have one at one
just got through holy cross again she a
couple years was an IRA it saved her
room boarded and they were non- taxable
it's been the traditional way in the
United States again to treat these
positions because they're not um when I
was back a million years ago when I was
at St anel I had other jobs on campus I
did clock in um I worked in I had a
great gig because I was a a student
athlete so I picked up the money and I
brought it the change that they made
that day and I brought it to the
academic building and it was 2 hours pay
best gig I've ever had in my life
carrying a sack of money but it was
something I clocked in I clocked in and
they gave me two hours for it I worked
in the library same thing I clocked in
they knew the hours and so it was a job
I had responsibilities being an RA is
much less precise most of the time no
one really wants to bother the ra um you
get called when you're needed some
especially we had a lot of young 17
year-olds at sameed my year and they had
a lot of problems getting used to a
college campus so I was dealing with
that a lot you'd have Friday nights you
might have an altercation or something
um you might have kids just any number
of things um personal problems other
things but they would come to you
sporadically most of the time I got to
study um I was getting paid while I was
there uh through my free room and board
and again non- tax it saved my family so
the third one's going to start at
Trinity next year she's going to be an
RA again very we could not afford all
these highered colleges with without
getting free room and board um so to tax
my family you would we figured it's
somewhere between 80 and 100,000 from me
to my children that has been saved in my
family again untaxed the system's not
broken I would say don't try to fix it
just keep the system we have where raas
are not treated as employees um other
reasons why that is important again I
never felt I was you know you're sort of
are you always on call maybe a little
bit around campus to students who there
were probably two or 300 people who
lived at Domin a call who might approach
you and you might give advice on things
from time to time but it wasn't like a
consistent nine-to-five job and most it
wasn't a job where you're punching in I
was very happy as was everyone I knew
and my children we very happy with the
systems of our Ras not being employees
um it didn't seem at the last Hearing in
the Senate we only were aware of one
incident at that time at Plymouth where
there was one student who might have
wanted to be an RA who might wanted to
have been treated as an employee other
than that we have a 100 Years of
everyone very happy with the system as
it is and so that's what this bill seeks
to clarify is that um an RA again is not
an employee thank
you thank you very much um are there
questions for the senator representative
McKenzie so let me maybe this just a
little bit
okay so Ras come to the college campus
um and can you explain to the committee
what the process is for bringing on an
IRA sure uh the nature of of the work
yeah uh where this is uh detailed are
there are there handbooks are there
other things that that uh they receive
uh do they um
they
interviewed uh and then who directs them
within the university
system um so I I'll just tell you what I
know and what what I lived and what my
children are doing as they are in other
states but they are active Ras so back
402 years ago or so um we did we had a
Ser you applied for the job or you
applied for the position on campus uh it
was going to be my junior senior year I
was watching my student loans increase
and um even though it was nothing
compared to what it is now for I think
it was $5,000 room board in tuition when
I went to St anom so the girls from
Darth can appreciate how cheap that was
I didn't at the time it was a lot of
money at the time um so I applied for
the job I think I had a first interview
um we happened to be a religious school
so there were a few priests there uh
staff from the campus there were
probably six or seven people who did my
first interview I think the second
interview was down to one or two and um
why did I want to do was I wanted the
free room and board um I didn't really
realize the things you're going to learn
while you're doing the job just like
when you sign up for the military or
something you learn lot more than you
thought you were um so you did you
learned how to interact with people you
had problems that you don't anticipate
they're going to come out you know
interaction of people living life in
front of you and you're sort of in
charge of keeping them somewhat in order
um and they can have problems from you
know over drinking I'm sure there were
many nights um especially the Freshman
found Heen repper and it was not a good
drink to start on um and so you learn to
deal with people and their problems
their relationship problems being far
away from home but again it's not
something you're doing all the time I
certainly was a varc athlete while I was
there um I had plenty of time I wasn't
on call that often I think I had one
weekend night the other nights you're
just mostly do your studying there as
opposed to the library and someone might
come by with a question or a problem or
something might develop
so thank you chairman if I could follow
up so you are applied yep for the job
yep you were interviewed for the job yep
and my children are the same at um
Trinity Holy Cross and Connecticut
College and uh at pen um they've all
went through a similar process so you so
you did that sounds very similar to what
a job would normal job would be so at
some point you discuss what the
compensation would be I for that
particular position now you may not
consider sure I don't think I knew what
it was I we were all aware anyone who
wanted to be in Ra was a whereare you
were going to get at the time I don't
know that it's still bored it was also
bored at my time it was room and boor um
so was a substantial chunka chain you
aware that you're going to get some
compensation in that form no cash most
of them I don't believe give you any
cash but that was compensation sure but
it was for an inexact job you don't know
you I I think some my floor happened to
be probably more of a problem floor uh
we had a lot of fraternity guys up there
we had the whole hockey team up there so
I probably had more disciplinary things
than others other floors um there were
other dorms much more quiet it's where I
wanted to be though there were the
people I knew so I chose that role but
it was I was I knew I would still be
able to do I could go travel do a sport
I could go study I had a full course
load it wasn't like a full-time job or
even an hourly job it was just it would
arise as it needed to be there would be
days I'm sure I did nothing um I also
got a shower so I was very happy I had
your own little bathroom so uh there
were that was another perk but it wasn't
like I was going to my other jobs on
campus that I had I had to actually
perform a task that I was assigned to do
someone was strictly on top of me this
was more of a looser thing that as long
as there were no big Pro and we in our
place we had uh there was AE of the dorm
it happened to be a priest at the time
he lived in the building so if there was
a major problem
um you'd you know interact with them and
they would more get involved with more
serious things but you were sort of a
lower level person who was just sort of
there if needed most of the time not
needed I a couple of final questions if
I could and then I'll I know a lot of
questions probably in the committee but
follow up followups so we have this this
process that you get hired
discussion about what the compensation
would be whether it be woman board
orever the case may
be uh were you
supervised sure so did we have booklets
I think you asked earlier yeah there was
a I'm I can't exactly remember but yes
and my children at their schools there
are pamphlets on like you know what do
you do if in certain situations I
believe we got there a week early um
which were you supervised I guess my I
didn't mean was I supervised not so it
was a loose loose as long as things were
going fine and there were the dorm
didn't get burnt down um people were
pretty happy so when things weren't
going fine there was something on a
Friday night or Saturday night I'm sure
there were a time or two that um the
again he was a priest he was in charge
of the building I'm sure if it was St
Patrick's Day weekend we were more
around than we would be in another time
would you be F followup sure I yes um
I'm sorry yes I'm sure I if I didn't do
the job if I wasn't there kids were
saying geez Bill ganon's never here we
have problems uh we just telling them a
light bulb I think they'd usually go to
me if the light bulb was out something
they'd tell and I'd tell the janitor
they'd fix it um so yeah you did have
other but again it was a very loose
thing that you no one was watching me
daily if there were problems they yeah
would interact and say you're going to
hang your job you Friday nights you're
on duty night you should be there most
of the time was pretty loose I was
traveling all over the Northeast running
and playing back basketball so it wasn't
something that I felt I was on call 247
I just was around when I needed to be
around great thank you and by the way St
is a great campus campus walk every day
okay it's beautiful place thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
bushard thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question thanks for having
me um do our receive a W2
form I don't I don't think we did I I
can't remember how we
uh I was young I wasn't making much
money at the time I was going to school
full-time so I don't think I I can't I'm
not sure I don't believe we did but
maybe we
do okay well it was a long time ago for
me that was my big question okay um I'm
sure we can find that out for you but um
so so if they okay follow up so if they
would be issued a W2 W2 form would you
consider them an employee I don't I
think this is a unique relationship I
think when I worked in the cafeteria or
I did other jobs I wasn't an employee
relation I performed a specific task
this is a much more loose system it's
been around in our country since Zan
as's 1892 I don't know when they started
but I know in the 20s and 30s they had
Ras um the systems worked fine I don't I
thought I was it was a fair exchange for
me and um again it was a tax-free
exchange I thought that was great saved
me money
allowed me to have my kids go to better
schools than they probably would
have thank you representative
svin thank you thank you for taking my
question um this um bill has five
sections to it um and each section deals
with a different piece of uh section of
the rsas and um I guess I'd like to look
first at section two um it indicates
that it deals with um RS
um addressing discrimination in the
workplace can you explain why it would
be a good idea to remove discrimination
protections um from someone in an RA
position I'm going to I have others who
are going to follow their attorneys or
people from the University system I have
I'm not as probably familiar with the
bill as I should be at this time to
answer that question so I I would I
haven't looked at it in about a month so
okay I apologize for that followup
follow I suspect your answer will be the
same but I also wanted to address um the
uh the section on uh wa a
minut workers compensation
um if with the concern that if a ra was
um injured while um performing their
duties as an RA um would you feel that
they uh should be either compensated or
at least have their uh
uh injury treated under the workers
compensation
law uh section six I know I didn't
testify it to it it is in the amendment
uh the
committee uh section six related to
unemployment compensation I was looking
at removed I was looking at section five
okay again I'll let other people after
me testify to that I know there are
people from the University system going
to testify thank you
representative Schulz thank you thank
you for can I say one thing
representative suin you asked me do I
feel if someone what was the
situation if they were injured while
performing their duties as an RA
shouldn't they um their injuries be
treated under workers
compensation I'd have to think about it
more thank you so thank you
representative sure my question um is
about I don't think this involves
College work study and if I'm curious to
know um if that was a consideration when
you wrote the Bill um since in a sense
it's sort of similar I mean it is
similar in the sense that you have to be
a student to do that
work but you get a paycheck instead of
room and
board so I see a difference there when
you get a paycheck I see a difference um
you may not the financial compensation
and the hourly work you said for what
what type position it's the federal
college work study
program um I would say that you're
probably doing more of a task on work
study as opposed
to you know I me not doing a specific
task not being on call
247 um I just I don't see it exactly the
same
now so it wasn't considered when you it
wasn't considered so the University
system came to me and I think they know
I went to S someone might have known I
had been an RA and we discussed the bill
and in it's that's where I I have others
who are better at it than I but I I like
the idea I enjoyed getting were uh being
at S A being an RA U my son who's now
going into highered it's it's developed
him into an outgoing person um it's done
a lot of things for
him and I the system has worked for me
as it's been in place for 100 years so I
don't again see the need to change
it
representative
Sullivan thank you again
um you talk a lot about the um UNH and
um the State University system um it
would appear the way this is drafted
that it would affect all colleges and
universities in New Hampshire is that
accurate yes that's
correct all of them would it surprise
you to hear that the um raas at
Dartmouth do receive a stipend which is
taxed um no I think they're going to
testify to that I just realized that
this morning um so it wouldn't surprise
me now thank
you representive
Stu good morning thank you for taking my
question um you have spoken a lot about
how this system has worked so well for
such a long period of time um why do you
feel that it's necessary to make these
changes right now I believe the
university came to me because nationally
it's not really an organic movement um
you know that people are trying they
want them nationally there's a movement
to try to include oura as workers um for
whatever reason be it unionizing or
whatever it is but it's a national
movement so the university system here I
think was trying to preempt that thank
you any further questions for the
senator
seeing none thank you very much for your
presentation before I call up the next
person uh a co-sponsor of the bill
Senator Waters cannot be here and ask
that a statement be read in and so
representative Sullivan offered to do
that since I look the most like Senator
Waters so this is addressed to the house
committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative servfaces that's us um
from Senator uh David Waters um and it
goes as follows I'm writing to explain
my opposition to the bill despite my
signing on as a co-sponsor having been
contacted by the University of New
Hampshire about the bill when it was in
its Drafting and having in my 39 years
at the University of New Hampshire
worked with many students who were
residential assistants it seemed at
first that employment status could be a
problematic um could be problematic due
to difficulties in defining work duties
and tracking hours however on a fuller
Fuller investigation it became apparent
that such employment status was not
incompatible with the duties of of the
work for students since other
educational institutions supported and
managed such employment status moreover
the changes proposed in this law would
in fact be intrusive to educational
institutions and of greatest importance
prevent students from exercising their
their rights and protections afforded
employees it is best to admit a mistake
and that is what I made in giving
initial support to this bill I would
encourage my colleagues in the house to
give careful consideration to the
limitations this bill would impose and
vote
itl thank you thank you uh next up I'd
like to call Katherine preventure who is
representing
uh
usnh speaking in support of the bill and
you have some written
testimony do
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh my name is Katherine
prenter I ser serve as the chief
administrative officer and the vice
Chancellor of Finance for our state's
University system I appreciate the
opportunity to speak with folks this
morning um to provide why the university
system supports Senate Bill
517 um Let me give some background on
how we got here with the bill the New
Hampshire Department of Labor conducted
an an inspection at Plymouth State and
that that revealed um disconnects or
gaps between current federal us do
guidelines that were issued back in 1993
actually under the Clinton
Administration and current state statute
federal guideline Federal us do
guidelines provide exemptions from the
definition of employee for Resident
assistance I'll call them raas some
schools call them community advis ERS
Etc so that was the Genesis for the bill
the um we the university system worked
with the New Hampshire college and
university Council we worked with the
New Hampshire Department of Labor um the
community college system supports the
bill also and that's how the L the bill
um got its legs and we reached out to
Senator Ganon for sponsorship with the
New Hampshire college and university
Council uh we seek status quo
effectively we've been operating under
these federal guidelines for decades and
the relationship between our resident
assistants and the campuses is such that
uh we do believe that this is an
educational opportunity for a number of
students our students are provided free
room and board they do not receive a W2
they are not taxed on um that benefit if
you will um frankly I think there are a
number of student students where they
not Ras they may not be able to afford
to enjoy a residential college
experience and um so I'm going to try to
answer some of the questions that I've
heard from Members this
morning um this does not impact other
work study students that would be
considered employees and do receive a W2
because it's specific with those fed
guidelines relative to educational
opportunities for for those students
that are provided that that are they do
apply there it's on it's online they do
and I I'll speak for the University
system institutions they are supervised
by a professional paid staff member um
as resident
assistants um I will say that there are
other sections of the bill I'll be
honest we we were f focused on the time
and wage part of the statute because if
we have to especially on the dining
piece if we have to re-examine how if
that's part of a student's
compensation um we may not in the
future credit the students
bill before the semester if we had to
pay that over the semester as the work
is done relative to the time and wage
statute which again would I think um
impact students financial aid and their
ability to pay their bill so on the
workers comp piece we don't take
exception to removing the workers comp
piece from the bill honestly on the
Discrimination piece we don't take
exception to that either we were trying
to be consistent again working with the
nhcu the New Hampshire Department of
Labor we are trying to be consistent
with language through out um codified
statute but we do not take exception to
that it was really the time and wage
piece we would like to continue the um
ability to credit our students for their
educational experience that they receive
while they are students on our campuses
as resident assistants and I I also want
to
mention this is by no means intended to
be a mechanism to
prohibit
unionization collective bargaining
agreements the
plrb retains authority to determine what
groups May organize and this was never
the intention of bringing this forward
it was really about keeping the status
quo and allowing our students to receive
free room and board without taxation at
the beginning of the semester and in
enjoying the educational opportunity
that an RA experience provides for our
students and I'm um let me just go look
at my the
questions I think I tried to answer some
of the questions I heard while I was
sitting here I'm happy to answer any
other questions um that you may have
right thank you uh one maybe if you
could address a question from a fellow
member Within the state there's
probably any number of models for how
this position would would operate and uh
the language to me looks kind of black
and white you're either an employee or
you shall not be an employee have you
considered how this might interact with
a a university that doesn't have a
strict room and board but may offer some
kind of stien or other uh financial
compensation that goes with this I I so
I'll my quick answer is no I would I
would guess that we need to look at
Federal do do laws relative to a stipend
is that
compensation and also probably refer to
the State Department of
Labor thank you representative
Schultz thank you for addressing adding
the college work study issue is that
still because I went to college 33 years
ago um is that still uh assigned based
on your financial need and is there any
Financial need consideration with uh
with Ras so let me answer your your
first question first so yes College work
study is part of a financial aid package
and does consider need and there could
be number of roles that a student could
apply for uh work on the campus that is
funded by work study you could be in the
book store you could be in the dining
hall you could work in athletics you
would receive a W2 for that work um on
the ra
position Financial need is not
necessarily considered there are
qualifications I think you need to be a
you need to be at least a sophomore you
have to maintain a 2.5 GPA and and other
um qualifications but uh I don't believe
need is necessarily part of that
calculus thank you further questions
representative St thank you um when I
watched the um hearing for the Senate um
the the person speaking for the
University system said that there was a
situation at Plymouth State College
which you also refer to where there was
some special program that Ouray at
Plymouth State participated in um that
was what ran a foul of the Department of
Labor could you give us um some some a a
broader explanation of that so that we
can understand what happened there and
why this law is needed everywhere
because of that special program thank
you it was the it was the if if memory
serves and if if you don't mind our
general council is behind me so I've
misspeak I hope you you wouldn't mind if
he corrects me um if memory serves
Plymouth state was providing
stipend on top of room and board
which one should receive a W2 for a
stipend and that was getting um sideways
with the
the the federal guidelines and the
employee so there were and I get
Department of Labor here is here also
and they obviously conducted the in
inspection but I believe that was part
of we we we were doing both and
shouldn't
have representative
suan um I think you partially addressed
this already but um can you explain why
you would include discrimination in the
workplace among those aspects of uh
workplace rights that are being removed
by this bill and as long as I'm added
also workers compensation as I said
earlier that again the I when the bill
was put together we're trying uh trying
to be consistent across all statutes
that Define
employee but again we do not take
exception to
removing those pieces of the bill on the
on the workers we're we're primarily
focused on the wage and hour portion of
of State
Statute follow follow um Senator Ganon
did um testify briefly about the section
six um which is no longer here um it was
amended out of the bill and
um it from what I saw in the Senate
hearing it appeared that um Deputy um uh
um commissioner um Richard lers uh came
to testify that the um um unemployment
is already excluded from um these types
of employees um so um I guess I guess my
point is that we it appears that it's
not a universal kind of thing
unemployment has already been excluded
um it seems like
um we don't have to eliminate all of
these pieces so thank you for your
thoughts on
that further questions represented
McKenzie if
tomorrow there was not one student that
want to be an RA on your
campus is it a position that is
important enough that you would have to
go to the market to fill those positions
yes absolutely and the critical point of
that is those federal guidelines that we
have been following since 1993 would not
exempt those people because there would
be no educ they
educational component because they
wouldn't be
students so yes we would have to
and we would have to go to market they
would be employees but they would not be
receiving an educational opportunity as
as a student on one of our
campuses F the question follow up um as
it relates to workers compensation there
were two parts of comp which is
indemnity and then there's a medical St
so if they if they're not um employees
under your
guidelines um they would not be eligible
for workers compensation so if you take
them out of that that
stream so you could
potentially and I'm ask you if you've
thought through this that what would
happen if somebody if an IRA was hurt in
the performance of their
Duty and now they find themselves
disabled what if they're out of the
workers comp
system and understand if they're out of
the comp system they're
also um they're also able to I believe
and comp will answer this Su the
university system because once you deny
them work as compensation the Qui pro
quo is that they have the the authority
to cor so I I don't if you thought that
through but if somebody was injured I
would think that you want to make sure
they were taken care of and I would
suggest that this bill's not doing that
maybe your attorney is can respond to
that again we do not take exception to
removing the workers compensation
section of this bill um I believe
they would have the ability to sue
us regardless they don't oh if they were
part of workers comp you mean they
wouldn't sue us again we do not take
exception to removing that part of the
bill represent
Susie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the
question when the bill was being thought
about or written was it ever taken into
consideration
um that a one siiz
fits-all may not work here because it
appears that there are other
universities across the state of New
Hampshire that do pay the RAS um so I'm
not sure that a one size fits all so is
this is this something you you guys
actually looked at at that point when
you was being written we
were again the goal was to keep status
quo with the federal
guidelines
and align State Statute with the federal
guidelines that colleges and
universities have been relying on for
decades representative Kum thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question going back to um what
representative McKenzie asked if you did
not have any students who were
interested in this Ro and you did have
to go to market would you also provide
as a benefit to that hired person free
room in board or would that be
considered part of their compensation
package if you went to Market if we went
to Market um we would likely have to
provide free room if it was a
requirement that they live on campus
presumably they would but we would not
have to provide free board
follow up followup please yes um so the
free room is would that be again non-
student non-educational requirement
would that be considered imputed income
so would they have to report that as
income as well I believe it's a
requirement do can answer this better
than I I believe if we require them to
live on campus it's not income
thank you I would like clarification
from the do if I could please on
that any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I very much
appreciate your time this morning thank
you we
turn
uh so next up I'd like to call and I'm
sor sorry I'm I'm not reading this very
well
Nadine lini
fora do you want to come up together or
you just want to come up in a in an
order all right so that's
fine and
so just making sure I have the record
correct I have you are Rowan Wade
hosana
tilahun wendeln Roland and naen
right all right
yeah all right um good morning Mr
chairman and uh members of the committee
thank you again for giving us this time
to testify
uh my name is hosana tahun I'm a junior
at Dartmouth College and I'm also a
student worker and uh ra for about 20
first year students on my floor um I'm
accompanied with um other student
workers from Dartmouth College many of
them who are also residential
advisers um so we were initially very
shocked to learn about Senate Bill 517
which legally delegitimizes the
important work of Resident assistant and
it declares that we are not employees um
just to establish the status quo
nationally residential assistants are
considered employees so this bill
effectively seeks to remove them from
that employee status just to reiterate
Ras are currently identified as
employees um we're here today taking
time out of our classes we're missing
classes right now um to testify against
this bill because we believe that
policies related to students and in this
case residential advisors need to have
input from those very workers um and
that's what we're doing here today
before I share the mic to um with my
fellow student workers I want to read a
testimony submitted by a UNH resident
adviser by the name of Emily who
couldn't join us
today she says I have in my three years
of attending the University of New
Hampshire held over five different
positions working alongside for the
University doing everything from handing
out letters in the mail room to editing
essays in the Connor's Writing Center in
that time no position has been as
intensive as my position as a resident
assistant multiple days of training on
everything from how to handle roommate
disputes to sexual assaults have taken
up the last two weeks of my summer for
the past 2 years as well as the final
selection of my January break and the
mandatory 2hour weekly meetings with my
supervisor and co-workers to refresh
information often and for good reason
while on duty I have to be prepared to
be the immediate responder to things as
small as noise complaints to as major as
sitting with a student while they
describe in visceral detail suicidal
fantasies to Psychological Services so
we can see how this role has changed
over the years even while I'm not on
duty I'm often never off the clock I
have weekly meetings with my supervisor
where I am briefed on new information
and asked to set goals on how to push
myself and do more in my role I hang
flyers on bulletin boards run weekly
activities for my residents and I have
to be cognizant of the state of over 45
people even outside of my building I am
not just a student as I am a mandatory
reporter for sexual assaults 24/7 even
if the student disclosing does not know
that in my capacity as an
RA this testimony is not intended to
demean the ra rule as along with being
one of the most challenging roles on the
UNH campus it has also been one of the
most rewarding but to deny me as an
employee of the university in this
capacity would be an insult to the work
I do daily thank
you my name is gwendelyn Roland and I'm
a junior at Dartmouth College I've
served in the position as a Dartmouth we
call it undergraduate advisor but
basically an R for the past two years um
and I just wanted to speak to a little
bit of the day-to-day and on the ground
responsibilities of a UG and an RA today
um so we do get hired um we have to go
through a lengthy interview process and
then after that we conduct about a week
and a half of training um and two days
of re refresher training before each
term so Dartmouth we're on quarters um
and we're also re-up on those trainings
during our weekly staff meetings every
week every Thursday um we also conduct
bi-weekly checkin meetings with our
supervisors um and as well as that we
have shifts where we walk through the
dorm buildings making sure that
everything is generally okay um we're
also as Emily um to reiterate her
testimony for UNH said um we're mandated
reporters as well um and we are on the
clock 24/7 to be available to students
um in our dorms by cell phone by email
if somebody has an issue big or small we
are their first point of contact and we
are also their first point of we're also
the administration's first point of
helping students who might not come to
us um so if we suspect any abuse as
mandate reporter we are also required to
report that even if a student has not
come to us we hear things we live in the
dorms and living in the dorms and having
our board paid for which to clarify as
well at Dartmouth um our compensation
for being ugas is a stipended which we
are taxed on we do receive a W2 at
Dartmouth um and as well we receive a um
compensation for a credit we receive a
meal crit credit for a meal plan the
lowest um meal plan on campus the one
that is least expensive that you can
have while living full-time on campus
and not in an apartment with a kitchen
um and we do not receive compensation
for room um but we have to be on campus
and our room and our board are not
necessarily part of our compensation but
rather the materials to do our job
effectively and well
um yeah I can also pass it off to Rowan
to speak a little bit more on the
necessity of being First Responders to
student mental health and sexual assault
and harassment
crises hi thank you all for your time um
I want to speak to the importance of
employee status when it comes to dealing
with the issues that residential
advisers have to deal with often on a
daily basis I do want to acknowledge
that this is not a job that can be build
hourly but most jobs that involve care
labor cannot be build hourly um and to
preface this I want to speak to my own
experiences um with my personal ug my
freshman year um I as well as many other
students um experienced sexual violence
and I was Reliant in my ug to walk me
through the process um without countless
hours of her labor I don't know how I
would have gotten through it she could
not have been build hourly for all the
time that she put into supporting me
through this process
because one that would have been dozens
of hours that I'm sure the college would
not have wanted to pay um and so part of
this is ugas have to navigate systems
that aren't well set up um and so part
of what we are trying to do as employees
and using employee protections is to
reform these systems to better protect
ugas when it comes to dealing with
issues of sexual assault and mental
health
crises
um and to that I want to comment on the
previous point that was made um during
previous testimony about this bill being
a union busting
bill
um as you may or may not know ugas um
and residential advisers across the
country have been uh unionizing not just
to get better compensation but to get
better employee protections because we
have to deal with unprecedented levels
of Mental Health crisis and with sexual
assaults Dartmouth has some of the
highest sexual assault rates in the
country and this is something that um ug
have to deal with um and they're not
properly supported by our institution
and the current policies that are set up
and so part of what we are trying to do
through um better protecting our
employees and by unionizing is to
develop systems that can better support
people who have experienced sexual
violence and are dealing with Mental
Health
crisis we are really really deeply
concerned that this is a bill that will
jeopardize people's safety
um by not allowing us to utilize our
status as employees to better advocate
for our residents and for ourselves as
workers
hi everyone my name is Nini I'm a junior
at darmouth college and I serve as a
newa for LX house the Latin American
Caribbean
house uh so ye we the ugas we are
compensated as we have said previously d
typend and a mu credit the lowest one
available and many other schools cover
include a housing
credit the students first apply for the
job through a lengthy and comp
competitive application process which
includes an interview and after that we
are awarded and offered letter with our
extensive responsibilities we also
undergo extensive training we attend
weekly staff meetings with professional
staff and as part-time employees and key
residential life staff for the college
our work is supervised by professional
staff and we can be fired if fired if we
do not fulfill the required
responsibilities and again we want to
highlight that we do receive Dar the W2
tax forms with our income recorded we
are
employees thank you for your testimony
um I do have a question you mentioned
that it isn't easy to determine hourly
commitment to this job um do you know
how your
University calculates hourly
compensation and establishes require or
compliance with the law for
employees thank you for that question um
so it differs per school but when it
comes to Dartmouth College um our hours
or our responsibilities are clearly
enumerated and they estimate that it's
about 15 to 20 hours a week they don't
reveal the methods and as we can see it
differs per residential advisor or ug in
this case undergraduate advisor um but
they say at minimum it is at least 20
hours a week
thank you other
questions representative
Clair thank you Mr chair thank you all
for your testimonies and for what you do
at the campus uh it's it's definitely
not an easy job and I appreciate your
work the um the stiping you get does
that include going to the trainings and
the meetings that you have weekly
bi-weekly however often you need to
go we do not get paid for the trainings
the dipen does not include the trainings
um I believe that our um bi-weekly
check-ins with our supervisors and our
weekly meetings are included in that at
least 20 hours a week um calculation but
again the college is not transparent
with exactly how they calculate that
number also to add on to that Dartmouth
calculates it about $6,000 a term um yes
representative
Bard thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and I I just want
to make it this
point clear that you are
considered employees by the Dartmouth
model OKAY follow up follow up please
and that model is shared with an awful
lot of other universities throughout the
country
further follow okay and so this bill
would be a unique
bill that would affect you
tremendously and the rest of the country
as well sets a standard if it were to
pass an inaccurate standard in
representation of our work thank
you representative
Kum thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony today and thank you for
taking my question um regarding the
training uh sessions that you guys have
to attend in those meetings with your
supervisors would you consider that part
of the educational benefit that you're
getting um in preparing yourself on on
Workforce training and everything else
so would that be an educational
benefit I would like I work several jobs
on campus um and I think that I benefit
educationally from all of
them that's all I'm going to say about
that I would also like to add many
things can coexist we can find
educational fulfillment in our work as
residential assistants but that has to
be paired with a serious consideration
of us as employees so both of these
things can coexist at the same time
further questions representative
Schultz this is a quick one um based on
the representation here today I can we
assume that the majority of the raas on
your campus are women or non
nonbinary but probably mostly women
given the topics you
handle I don't have the exact statistics
off the top of my head but it is a a job
that is
disproportionately um fulfilled by women
and non-binary people um often times
because we are at the Forefront of these
issues on campus funny how that works
thank
you representative
McKenzie thank you and thank you for
coming today and missing class and all
those other things that you that you had
to do get here today thank you so
much so you mentioned uh that there are
other jobs that you do within the
university
system uh are the other jobs um are they
hourly jobs so you you compensated on an
hourly basis for these other
jobs
yes I can um speak to that I think all
of us work multiple jobs here um this is
a a job position that often is fulfilled
by working class and low-income people
and so we do have to work multiple jobs
I work several jobs some are paid via
stiens some are paid hourly um but all
of them are
jobs yeah depends again all of us here
work several jobs uh I am an
international student so I I need all
the jobs to afford to live in this
country and to come and to commute from
from Brazil my home country some of the
jobs we work are early paid and some are
not some such as research which which
still constitutes as
work follow up follow up you mentioned
that the responsibility for
ra is a
24-hour uh
responsibility so can we assume that you
could get calls at 3:00 in the
morning um could you get calls when
you're do another job correct and could
we could I ask you how you resolve those
conflicts if you're working someplace
els for pay and all of a sudden you get
an ra ra call how do you how do you
resolve those
issues I think it would naturally depend
on the issue um I have gotten knocks on
my door at 3:00 a.m. and sometimes I
have woken up and sometimes I have not
um in terms of if I'm working an hourly
job and I get a call I think it would
definitely depend on what the call is
and depend on what job I'm working I'm
very lucky and most of the hourly jobs
that I do work at Dartmouth um have
wonderful supervisors and so if I told
them that a resident needed my help most
of the time I could clock out early and
I think that if it was serious enough I
would final follow follow so can you
describe what the what it's like to be
uh on call 24 hours a day in a very busy
uh University and
so because not many jobs on call 24
hours a day let's put it that
way um honestly it can get hectic um but
we were told when we apply and when we
interview that this is the nature of the
job so it wonderfully attracts uh people
who are prepared for this um on top of
that we the day-to-day looks like as
Gwen had acknowledged before for um
keeping our our phone open our email
open our communication lines open so we
move daytoday um recognizing that this
is a very this is an important reality
and we're prepared for
that and one final question Mr chairman
do you think there's value um to having
you this
consistent um relationship with the
students throughout the thing as opposed
to a private system where potentially
you could have all kinds of people
rotating through the the college system
is there value in the in that consistent
kind of support that you provide in that
role as the
AR um yes especially given the nature of
the job when you're dealing with um
mental health crises and sexual violence
you need to have you know relationships
built up with your residents built up in
a way that they trust you enough to talk
to you about about these issues and I
think that also speaks to the inadequacy
of a lot of other systems that are in
place on campus to support people with
these issues and why our position is so
needed I would also like to speak to the
particularity of each campus um in terms
of where you can find the resources they
might not always be standardized it's
very helpful to have somebody who really
understands what it's like being a
student at that organization um in terms
of knowing the acronyms knowing knowing
the language um and things of that
nature I would also like to say that our
supervisor our direct supervisor
position um at Dartmouth specifically
has a lot of turnover and it negatively
affects the ability with which they are
able to do the job and it also yes
yes thank you representative
Kum thank you again thank you again for
taking my question um with regard to the
other jobs that you you guys are holding
or other jobs that you're even aware of
that maybe you're not holding are there
other jobs on the campus that provide
free room and board or something that's
comparable to free roomin board as far
as the value that I'm assuming that it's
quite a substantial value getting free
roomin board in a year of your your
college um attendance so is there
another job that holds that same value
I would like to remind you that
Dartmouth students are not um
compensated with a room credit we do not
get our room paid for we still pay the
housing that we
are if you are not on financial aid then
you would pay the sticker price for
housing um if you are a ug at Dartmouth
um some
research I think I'm I I think um
does get up to that amount and also if
you um there are shorter term positions
that provide um room and board in terms
of supporting darmouth reunions and
darmouth commencement which I have
fulfilled um which
yeah any further questions
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
as I've heard from multiple Witnesses
uh you must be you you must have
attended the school at least for one
year before you can apply to be an RA
correct follow up so that you have no
idea when you're applying for colleges
if you'll have this opportunity if
you'll be in ra or have some other jobs
you just know that you want to go to
that school and what it might cost you
correct and and follow up and and
further that the opportunities uh you
you have to serve you have to live on
campus and you have to be available all
the time there's no way to calculate
really what your hours are uh it seems
it would be unreasonable to have an
hourly an hourly uh relationship there I
I don't know where the I want anxious to
hear from the department but you uh you
have other opportunities such as perhaps
in your graduate year to be to be
teaching and you're still not considered
an employee is that
correct or are you an employee if you're
teaching if you're a grad student and
teaching lower
class you're not there yet right are you
speaking to um like graduate students
PhD and master students right and can
you repeat your question for us please
yes so if you are you you're a grad
student and you're teaching lower class
taking really doing the job of Faculty
your ad grad student faculty and you're
teaching do are you considered an
employee
then so grad students are still
considered employees especially if they
are teaching assistants in fact many
programs come with a stipend so the
stipend sort of model is not unique to
just undergraduate students residential
advisers but also carries through um to
The Graduate Community thanks very much
thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony
next up I'd like to call Debbie Sky who
represents the New Hampshire College
University Council uh testifying in
support of the bill with written
testimony to go
well good morning thank you so much for
the opportunity to offer testimony and
support of
sb57 relative to the appointment status
of University students working in
educational programs I'm Debbie skiri
and I serve as the president of the New
Hampshire college and university Council
and we respectfully request your support
for
s517 um for those of you who aren't
familiar with nhcu it's a um Consortium
of most of the colleges both public and
private institutions of higher education
in our state and these institutions are
recognized and highly regarded for their
outstanding teaching research community
service activities as well and they
serve as major centers of activity that
are vital to the economic development
and Workforce Development of the
community and our
state s SP 517 seeks to Simply provide
much needed clarification ation of the
employment status of college and
university St uh students serving as
resident assistants and in other
educational programs our members
appreciate and support this effort to
make this important distinction for
those students working in these
educational programs the nhcu member
institutions actively seek to offer our
students multiple opportunities to
offset expanses rather expenses related
to college attendance and I think uh
earlier Senator Ganon did a great job of
kind of outlining his um own experience
and those of his children serving as
resident assistants and that can be
certainly one strategy to help make
College more affordable and this
clarification between the federal
guidance and our local laws will ensure
the students who may not have this
financial means to live on campus may be
able to explore that option and that's
very valuable
experience our colleges and universities
will also directly benefit as a passage
of SB 517 will better will allow for
better alignment between the federal
guidance which was enacted under the
Clinton Administration and our state
guidance as it relates to the employment
status of students working in
educational programs according to the
federal guidance students enrolled in
Bonafide educational programs who are
reg residential assistants and receive
reduced room or board charges or tuition
credits are not generally considered
employees under the
flsa this federal and state alignment
will be helpful to our institutions and
especially to those who have campuses in
multiple States further it will
streamline the operations it will reduce
administrative costs while also leading
to cost savings for our institutions and
far more importantly our students and
their families thank you thank you very
much um I do have a question so in the
last
testimony we heard a description of how
Dartmouth operates and it sounds to me
like at that University they've created
a model for this position that's
different from the traditional ra
Arrangement and in fact is an employee
like position so my question
is when you have uh a change in law that
says this shall be an employee and this
shall not does it take into
consideration perhaps another model that
might exist that that doesn't match the
either
or I'm not an attorney and you will hear
from attorney in a in a minute or two on
this but it seems to me that what we're
seeing is that there's a lot of
flexibility perhaps at the federal level
to Define it in many ways and I think a
little bit of that has already come out
in this hearing this morning and I think
what the idea is behind sort of the
alignment is to allow for Flex a little
bit more flexibility perhaps than we've
previously seen and we just want to um
just continue I think of what's been
working in the state um and as uh Miss
prenter said earlier you know really
talking about status
quo thank you further questions
representative Susi thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question I'm G to go back to your
written testimony it says our college
and university will directly benefit of
the passage of sb517
so my question
is it's taken the university system of
New Hampshire to come many years to come
to this point with this um
legislation um and other than besides
the fact that they want to come on board
with the federal and or align themselves
with the feds um is there a bigger
problem has this with what you're doing
now is this created a a problem for the
University system because it doesn't
appear that it's been a problem until
now so is there is there an issue is
there a larger problem yeah I don't
believe so we've you know certainly in
talking with our campuses and so forth
we're hearing that it's it's working
fine but you know um some additional
sort of clarification um is necessary
and I think that's the point that we're
actually at right now you representative
Solen thank you for taking my question
um I'm not familiar with the New
Hampshire uh college and university
Council um does that include all of the
colleges and universities in the state
of New Hampshire it includes uh
certainly the university system is one
of our members the private colleges with
the exception of Dartmouth uh Thomas
Moore and Magdalene College I may have
left another one out but pretty much
everyone thank
you further
questions representative
McKenzie thank you Tony appreciate it um
is it generally uh the position or does
the University uh
group generally take positions on labor
law we do not labor
standards we do not thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimon thank
you next I would like to call Reverend
Dr Gail Kenny representing oursel and
the Meredith Meridan Congregational
Church in opposition to the
Bill thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee um again for the record my
name is Gail Kenny I'm a resident of
Kanan New Hampshire I'm a church pastor
and I am speaking on behalf of the
Meridan congregation Church which is
part of the United Church of Christ um
in my role as a pastor I've had the
privilege of working with a number of
college students um in ways that have
been truly inspirational for me and in
this capacity working with students I
just happen to stumble over Senate Bill
517 um which to me came across as a very
odd Bill to try to change labor law to
declare at New Hampshire colleges or
universities that undergraduate resident
Hall advisers or assistants should be
excluded from the definition of employee
in certain labor laws so I was curious
what the heck is this so I attended the
Senate hearing to figure out what was
going on and folks from the University
of New Hampshire were the key advocates
for the bill and try as I might though I
could not figure out what the problem
was that they were trying to address and
typically in New Hampshire we don't like
to pass laws if there's no reason to if
there's no problem that needs to be
dealt with that's sort of not our way um
the testimony um mentioned in my
recollection mentioned um hourly wages
and maybe the challenge of tracking
hours worked but the reality is and and
this has been mentioned that the federal
fair labor standards act already tells
colleges and universities that they
don't have to pay the minimum wage or an
hourly wage and they don't have to pay
overtime uh for Resident advisers or
resident assistants they can if they
want but they don't have to so if that
is already federal law that that
colleges and universities including in
New Hampshire both public and private
don't have to pay an hourly wage or
don't have to pay the minimum wage and
that's already covered what is the
problem what is the problem here that we
are trying to deal with with a new bill
in the New Hampshire legislature and and
to this moment and even hearing the
testimony I still can't figure it out
and even in terms of tracking hours in
this day and age of Technology of high
technology we've already seen from other
college campuses that it's not difficult
to track the hours of an RA if you need
to or if you want to um so the original
version of Senate Bill 517 also asserted
that um resident um assistants or
advisers that it was just an
extracurricular activity but you know
that was so far removed from reality
that even the Senate Commerce Committee
and its wisdom said we need to take this
out this is not a an extra curric
activity this is a job the other thing I
want to just mention just from hearing
the testimony the ra of 100 years ago is
not the ra of today the ra of 40 years
ago is not the Raa of today and every
job if done well or every job done by a
dedicated worker who wants to do their
job well provides Educational
Opportunity it's not just this job it's
all work provides an opportunity to
learn and to train and to grow if you
want um so the the truth is the reality
is that the
31-year-old exclusion that exists today
in the fair uh Fair Labor sta uh acts
Fair labor standards acts wage and hour
component um is really from another era
and it absolutely doesn't reflect the um
the demanding R job of today and so as
far back as
2011 uh there's a I I found a um a
national law firm that's sort of
tracking these things nationally and
back in 2011 they advised their educ
institution clientele by way of a
newsletter um that the understanding of
the job of Ra was evolving and again the
in 2017 so quite a while ago the
National Labor Relations Board ruled
that Ras were indeed employees based
specifically on things that they looked
at that the duties that they uh that
they performed specific services in
exchange for compensation of some kind
compensation varies in its model from
from college or campus to campus but
that they uh Ras receive compensation um
they they job again this is what the
National Labor Relations Board um in its
ruling said ra job duties and
expectations are carefully outlined in
some detail these individuals are
supervised by college or university
staff they're subject to discipline up
to an including termination there's
written documentation of their hiring in
their work agreement with work
expectations excluded and these are
employee elements if this isn't an
employee folks then what is and I did
interesting thing so I looked up what
UNH has to say about raas and they start
off by saying that Ras are
paraprofessional staff members is a Prof
a paraprofessional staff member an
employee or is it not um so I looked up
three colleges I looked up UNH I looked
up Dartmouth and I looked up New England
college and I I'll give you just some of
the things that I pulled out that that
uh provision after provision and the
things that these these colleges and
these campuses have put in writing
screams out these are employees these
follow the definition of
employee and um so in their own words
just take their own words for what they
are
um so and so I I won't go into that
because I'm GNA give you everything but
um there's
just how can I when I looked at just
those three colleges
I just asked myself and I ask you to ask
yourselves looking at what they say
about who raas are what they do what
they're expected to do how they're hired
that they are faced with firing that
they are compensated how can anybody
with a straight face say but that's not
an employee and so the question is if
they're not an employee what are they I
know that there are a number of people
in this committee who are very familiar
with issues of workfor worker
misclassification and you know want to
be very careful about that I know this
is something that's come before the
committee a lot but we shouldn't be
going back to the dark ages of
misclassification so um I just want to
read um just in closing um a publication
called inside higher ed published an
article about um campus undergraduate
resident assistance um in
2022 and this was after talking with
some Ras from across the country I sent
people out they did some interviews
across the country country and the
article included their article included
these comments resident assistants also
known as resident advisors Community
advisers Hall leaders leaders and Myriad
other titles play a crucial role in the
administration of residential life at
colleges and universities they organize
social events for underclassmen report
dangerous or illicit behavior and even
act as first responders during medical
and mental health emergencies
compensation for these roles
varies from free or reduced room and
board to stiens or hourly wages every ra
or CA that spoke to inside higher ed
said that as student workers they
shoulder too heavy a burden and work far
more hours than the job should entail
moreover they said they aren't given the
respect or the compensation they deserve
every student worker interviewed for
this article said that while they enjoy
organizing community events and helping
their peers being an RA was for them a
job they saw themselves as an employee
of their institution a job that felt
that they felt was rewarding but whose
main purpose was to help them and their
families earn a living or make ends meet
this is our livelihood they said so
these student workers um as you'll see
from the handout that I'll give you
reflect all all the elements of being
employees and this bill is so confusing
in its um contradictions that I would
just say J it's not ready for uh prime
time and it really does need to be met
with inexpedient to legislate so thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there
questions seeing none thank you again
next up I would like to call Claudia
stelle um speaking in opposition to the
bill for her
yourself good morning chair and members
of the committee and thank you for
hearing my testimony I did email it to
everyone earlier because my printer
wasn't being cooperative um I live in
aworth I'm Claudia stelle I'm a member
of the economic Justice Mission group of
the New Hampshire Conference of the
United Church of Christ um this bill
seeks to specify that a particular group
University students um who including
students serving as resident Hall assoc
assistants or dormatory counselors who
are participating in a Bonafide
educational program are not considered
employees under New Hampshire labor law
and I find this disturbing for several
reasons um first as we've pointed it
this has been pointed out many times
already is that the students who are
serving as resident Hall assistants are
going through a process of that would
classify them as employees under any
other sector of the economy they have to
be interviewed they have to they have to
apply they're interviewed they're hired
they are
supervised um they have to meet
expectations they can be disciplined
including being fire if they don't meet
those
expectations um
and they um and they have to meet a set
schedule of time commitment and they
receive compensation so in any other
area of the economy that's the
definition of an employee second of all
the Resident assistant as we've heard of
today have totally different
responsibilities and and a much more
complicated um set of responsibilities
than those of some of us of a certain
age and including myself who maybe in
our experienc resident assistance um
help people get into their room with the
door was locked they'd lock their key
inside or if uh they were told to turn
down their music to be considerate of
other people um but the other thing
that's I think is really important and
I'm not positive
has been emphasized enough is that in
those situations of decades ago there
was also um the college hired
experienced adults to be in charge of
the dormatory to live either in the
dormatory OR nearby to handle more
serious issues today's resident
assistants um are asked to be exemplary
leaders and models of conial inter um
interpersonal interactions they are to
set a friendly and comfortable um tone
for a dorm lifestyle they're expected to
organize activities based on students
interests they cope with problems
between roommates they um support the
college rules and policies they
cooperate with campus security to
maintain safety they help enforce
College Health and Welfare policies and
to be prepared to do all those things
they're required to do a lot of training
and also have um periodic supervised
meetings they're both trusted allies and
they are enforcers of the rules and
they're likely as we've heard many times
to be the first person to help students
cope with physical or mental illness
they may be the first person to respond
to a student who's been sexually
assaulted or has overdosing from
drugs the college would be very
hardpressed to serve their students well
outside of the classroom without having
people like resident assistants to help
students during the night and over the
weekends third is that they are often
overworked and undercompensated oops
excuse me I lost
my well I'll just go for my notes um we
already know that they are are required
to work to supervise or be um a number
of
dormatory students sometimes somewhere
between 20 and 50 they have to um be on
be specifically in the dorm at certain
hours plus they're on call me um and
have to be on campus during special
weekends um so that they are
available
um so I
apologize um they also need this job to
make ends meet and we've heard from the
from the dart withth withth women that
they hold many jobs on campus I would
say that going to school is a full-time
job and that working as a resident ass
assistant is is a a part-time job and
that that's more than enough to do I'm a
an adjunct in the community college
system in New Hampshire and I can say
that students I the students I see hold
have staggering load on their plates
they attend classes they work they
support they are they have families
children Elders that they care for and
they're financially insecure and they're
challenging themselves educationally I
don't see I I think that our resident
Associates who are doing this job to
make ends meet to be able to attend to
afford to attend college
they need to have the the security of
being employees and all of the benefits
that come with that my fourth point is
that if we're carving out one set of
employees to or one set of workers to
not be considered employees who's the
next group that we're that's going to be
cons going to
be Declassified if you will and finally
um I would ask how would raas who are
hired in these colleges know that
they're not employees if this law passes
because I would say that those students
all of their work experiences have been
as employees and if they are being
interviewed for a job they're being
given specific uh duties and specific
times requirements to be there and
compensation whether it's monetary or
not or not that they would understand
that it's being employees who's going to
tell them that they're not employees
because that might it change how they
how they think about the the position so
with all of that I would encourage you
to vote this itl please thank you for
your testimony are there
questions seeing none thank you again
thanks uh the last card that I have for
this bill is from Danielle Albert uh
representing the New Hampshire
Department of Labor they are not taking
a position on the bill
good morning my name is Danielle Albert
I'm the Deputy Commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of Labor I'm here
today with our General councel John
garrian um we will try to be brief uh
I'm anticipating some questions so in
general uh as representative seaworth
noted the department doesn't take a
position on this bill we are neither
neither in support of it nor in
opposition to it we have reviewed the
language um of the bill we're familiar
with it U We believe We Understand its
stated intent um have also heard from
and and had some correspondence with the
university system we understand their
expressed need uh for for the um that
was the impetus for uh this language in
some what we understand the language to
be doing and and it is a very brief
summary it is creating an exemption to
the uh definition of employee in RSA 275
at three specific points sections 4
sections 36 and sections 42 um it is
also creating uh an ex uh exemption to
the definition of employee and RSA
2791 which is relative to minimum wage
payment and it is creating an exemption
in the workers compensation statute uh
to the presumption of employment um
which falls under the definition of uh
employee and there were some questions I
I think uh perhaps representative
McKenzie and maybe representative
Sullivan as well um had asked how that
worked on in the workers compensation
context we understand the proposed
language to be removing um the
presumption that applies uh all all
individuals with the exception of the
specifically enumerated or presumed to
be employees under the workers
compensation statute so it's not a
blanket um carve out that you are barred
from the workers compensation system but
it is removing the benefit of that
presumption from this class of employee
um and we are so that's our
understanding of the of the language um
as it currently stands we're happy to
answer any questions that there may be
thank you very much uh so questions I'll
start with representative
Sullivan thank you um thank you for
taking the question um I'm not sure I
followed What You indicated on the
workers compensation
um the way let me see if I can rephrase
from I heard you say that the it removes
the presumption that they are employeed
so as it stands now if someone filed a
worker's comp claim as an RA it would be
presumed they're an employee and they
would um if their situation warranted it
they would be covered by the uh workers
compensation that would be correct So
currently as it stands um all employees
except for direct sellers certain types
of residential placement providers and
there's a third one in the current um
current statute uh which I'm not
remembering off the top of my head are
not presumed to be employees this would
be adding a fourth class of um employee
or fourth class of individual who would
not be presumed on its face to be an
employee under the statute so if the
language were to go into effect and an
RA or a dorm counselor were to be
injured and put forward a workers
compensation claim um they would not be
presumed on their face to be an employee
of the employer and they would carry the
burden of demonstrating in a dispute
that they actually were one follow
follow um how would one go about um
proving that they're employee if this
went went through what does what does
that you know involve yeah that's a very
very good question it it's going to be I
think somewhat fact specific because all
jobs you know are different and um but
the factors that are listed in the
workers compensation statute um
typically when someone's presumed to be
an employee an employer then can rebut
that there's something else utilizing
those seven specifically enumerated
criteria um in this instance the uh
purported employee if the language goes
through would need to be demonstrating
the employer has care and control over
my my work we've engaged in that uh some
kind of employment uh For Hire that has
terms uh set for it um they tell me time
place uh all of those different factors
they would need to bring forward and
demonstrate to verify or to prove that
they're
employees well again well um different
uh area um I I believe I heard early uh
testimony that minimum wage is already
excluded um for um these types of
employees um first of all is that
true so I in my understanding and the
crafting of the current language is that
part of the intent was to resolve um or
or sort of marry up the way that the US
do Under the flsa is looking at resident
advisers and dorm counselors or
Community advisers or whatever term um
is used if we look at the US do
interpretation um as it's set forth
through the field operations manual that
they utilize um they are I've got the
definition here with me so I'm just
going to refer to it if you bear with me
for one moment um in general they are
construing that these raas or dorm
counselers who are participating in a
Bonafide educational program and who
receive remuneration if I pronounce that
correct IR ly in the form of reduced
room or board free use of telephones
tuition credits and the like are not
employees under the act so um our
understanding uh again in the impetus
and from speaking with the University of
New Hampshire who um had had some hand
in crafting of this language was they
were looking to resolve how us do is is
is treating this type of individual with
how the state is so under the current
state statute
um there are ways and there are
certainly scenarios where resident
advisers or dorm counselors um can be
construed as or or fall within the
definition of employee for the purposes
of minimum wage and other protective
legislation requirements as well as
workers compensation as it currently
stands um and I think it was Miss
preventure who had referenced it in her
testimony some of the impetus for the
bill um was an interaction that the
department had through uh a inspection
that was undertaken through the
University of of Plymouth University
I believe um where there was a
determination that Ras had crossed into
that line of employment um or were it
were employees of the
University thank you so I saw a number
of hands I'm going to try to catch them
in the order that I saw them and so
representative bushard you had a
question thank you Mr chair um
representative
Sullivan two of his questions were mine
okay G ask him I'm okay okay all right
uh representative
love thank you for taking my question uh
given that um these Ras have uh have a
wide a wide array of responsibilities
some uh really going into law
enforcement and uh you know in a case of
sexual assault or or EMT uh duties and
stuff um if someone were to be hurt by
uh by anra unintentionally or
intentionally um who would be like
uh to clarify your question are you
asking under current iteration of law or
if the proposed language were to go into
effect both
both excellent it's an excellent
question so under current iteration of
Statute so as as currently written you
know if an RA were injured uh in the
course of of their um ra duties and they
asserted a workers's compensation claim
I'm going to focus on the workers
compensation um component first um they
could pursue a claim through the routine
channels you know it would be reviewed
by the insurance carrier there's a whole
process under the workers compensation
statute for um those types of reviews so
that determinations can get made and if
it's disputed there would be a right in
that the sense that the insurance
carrier said we don't either think it
rises to the level of a work injury or
we don't think there's an employee
employer relationship um it could be
disputed through the department at A
administrative hearing um in which again
that presumption would attach
because they're not otherwise Exempted
from the presumption under current
iteration of law if they're not if it's
not an employee if it has nothing to do
with workers compensation and workers
compensation is only going to apply
where you have an employee employer
relationship um I imagine there's other
recourse out there I don't know I'm not
it's been a bit since I've been in
school myself I remember there being
forms of health insurance I don't know
if that could go through health
insurance um I don't know what other
types of programs could be out there
whether private suit or of some sort
would be um applicable um that would be
if workers compensation were not at
issue um if the language as proposed
goes into place again that will alter uh
the burden if an RA or dorm counselor or
whatever term we're using were to assert
a worker's compensation claim um they
would carry the burden of demonstrating
that they are indeed an employee under
the purposes of the workers compensation
statute such that the uh University as
the if determined yes employers as the
employers uh insurance carrier would be
liable to take care care of that injury
if the determination was that they were
not again those other mechanisms would
be available Private health insurance
any other program that's out there
private suit um whatever else may be
available follow up clation um that that
I was interested in that too that was
going to be my next one um Let me let me
try to clarify if say for instance uh I
come in I'm I'm an RA and I come into a
situation where there's been a sexual
assault and the person has been injured
and I move them and they get further
injured who's liable that's a very good
question I honestly am not 100% sure
that I know the answer to that off the
top of my head that's almost like a a
almost like a responding you know I'm
responding providing the first aid um
type of thing and further injury has
occurred and then who's liable for the
further injury um I don't know I'm happy
to try to take a look at that and get
back to you um but I don't know off the
top of my head I think that's a little
outside sort of labor law it's it's I
think it's a question somewhat outside
of labor
law because if if I'm in the in the
performance of my duties uh you know in
a regular job uh that you know my
employer would generally carry an
insurance for that um you know that
that's and we're if we're not going to
have them as employees well now sure and
it's just so to make sure that I
understand you're asking about further
injury to the person that you're
responding to as opposed to the person
who's providing the response um yeah
it's a very good question I I I would
have to look I honestly don't know it's
outside the confines of what workers
compensation would provide for workers
compensation is only going to provide um
time out of work benefits medical
benefits and everything else that's
enumerated under that statute for
injured employees um just like the sort
of what we call wage and hour laws are
going to provide for parameters Andor uh
around payment of wages and other things
for the employees but not necessarily
folks who are outside of those
relationships thank you representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss Albert for taking my question uh it
seemed earlier the uh Miss proventure
was willing to uh get rid of some of the
questionable parts of this bill but I
wonder if uh section four where we're
changing 279 to address the minimum wage
I wonder if we just had that would would
that uh answer the main question without
uh changing them from being an employee
in general we just because we can't if
we can't calculate the number of hours
that they were actually on call and
ready and waiting to do their work uh to
see if their value of either their their
stien or their room in board equals
seven and the
quarter uh if we just get rid of this
maybe we're done and just to make so my
apologies just to make sure I understand
are you referencing the first
the first um section that the language
is proposing at RSA
27542 2791 2791 oh section four my
apologies I was thinking section four in
in the statute um so my apologies do you
mind repeating the question one more
time yes what what I'm wondering is if
if uh everything else if we if we could
just wave the minimum wage requirement
because we they find it difficult to
manage that and they're not held uh to
that standard does that solve the main
problem and leave them as employees for
other
purposes that's a very good question I
in effect what it would do is it would
alleviate um it would remove from the
definition in RSA 279 the minimum wage
law Ras from Counting as employees if
you don't amend it in other areas um
you're going one from a very technical
standpoint there are already a variety
of different definitions of employee
across labor sta statutes um and then
outside of of the department of labor
labor statutes labor statutes as a whole
um so you would now have another
iteration to to throw into the mix um I
think we would have to look at or really
contemplate whether or not removing the
definition under 2791 would have
interplay with RSA
275 um in particular RSA 275 is setting
the some of the tone about notification
about rates of pay and sort of other
employee um protections it's ctive
legislation um so to remove it from one
I think we would have to sort of
contemplate could there be a an outcome
that was unanticipated from doing it in
one one of those areas and not the
other right we certainly don't want
unintended consequences but we just we
do want to fix this
problem doing it without undoing them as
employees right thank you um I want to
since I think we've hit every other
section uh representative Sullivan asked
earlier under
27536 where it's under discrimination in
the workplace do you have an idea of
what the impact of changing the
definition in that section might be as
um as currently written in the current
um proposed language I mean by amending
the definition at RSA
27536 it means uh that raas and dorm
counselors would not count as employees
for the purposes of the specified
discriminatory sections um
36 and 3 seven if I'm I'm doing this
from memory so forgive me if I'm a
little off um are in particular uh about
prohibitions and uh rights that attached
to employers who violate that
prohibition on uh discrepancy and pay so
no no discriminating between um like
jobs across genders and so it would
remove it would remove that uh
requirement from the from the dep it
would remove that raas and dorm
counselors from Counting as employees
for the purposes of those stated
sections so they would no longer apply
all right thank you uh represent Broody
I'm sorry if I could I just add that the
it's important to note that that section
in 275 is separate and apart from uh
354a which is the Civil Rights Act that
covers a lot of other discriminatory
practices thank you represent proced um
if you spoke I was going to ask you what
your name is again because I missed it
at the beginning all right it's John
garrian with a g g a r r i g a n oh
there was a card sorry but then no
that's that was what he submitted for
the other my apologies I didn't put both
our names on the pink card so my
apologies and finally representative Bui
finally I know there's other are you
sure thank you Mr chairman oh thanks for
taking my question um I really wasn't
intending on asking any but um I've
heard the term
students are employees I've also heard
that if they get hurt it's their burden
to prove their
employees now what if they do the
carrier is going to say they're not
covered under the workers comp nobody's
paying a premium for them as employees
how would that be covered would that be
like a blanket policy like on your
homeowners policy if somebody's working
on your property and gets hurt I I don't
I don't honestly don't know and that's
why I'm asking a question yeah it's an
excellent question um And to clarify
under the proposed language um were it
to go into effect that's where the ra
dorm counselor um would need would carry
the burden of establishing that they are
an employee currently under current
iteration of Statute that presumption
would attach and on its face they're pre
presumed to be employees if determined
not to be an employee um I think under
either iteration of the statute um it
would not be the liability of the
compensation system because in order to
trigger that liability you've got to
establish that employee employer
relationship under the parameters that
are set under 281a and then it would be
a question of what other mechanisms are
available in these types of instances
now the homeowner's policy that you're
referencing there is a specific
requirement in the workers compensation
statute that homeowners and renters have
to have aider yeah some kind of rider
that's covering injuries um that occur
on properties and it's it's a require
that' be written into all of those
policies no similar requirement exists
in the workers comp statute uh for other
types of scenario so again I think it
would be is it health insurance is it
some other benefit that's non-w workers
compensation related and maybe non-
labor law you know Labor Law related
that the uh University is carrying um is
there some other benefit out there that
could potentially pick that up okay
there a followup so what if they are
deemed to be employees
now the workers comp system is not
covering them because nobody's paying
premiums for them and the other way like
if they got hurt now there's mechanisms
in place to take care of them but that
wouldn't that lawyer is going to say
we're not paying for that they're
employees the workers comp system should
be paying that so I think something
should be put in some word it should be
put in and I I off the top of my head I
can't think of it but an overlapping
thing here and it's it could be and it
can't be sure and um it should be
addressed I sure I I completely
understand what you're explain mean I
think from a regulatory perspective if
there's a determination let's say a
dispute came up and the determination
again under either iteration of language
current status or proposed status
there's a a a determination in a dispute
from the Department yes you meet that
threshold um that's either upheld by the
compensation appeals board if appealed
or whatever you know Supreme Court or
however far it may go but if the final
deter ation is yes you meet the
definition of employee under the workers
compensation statute um the department
would be looking at at the insurance
carers that's a claim that's a claim I
mean that's a claim that there would be
responsibility for I I understand I
think there would be some um maybe
behind the the scenes complication on
hey we're not charging premium based off
that from our audit audits are regulated
through the department of insurance so
I'm not I'm I'm just a little bit burst
how they work so if the appeals board is
the bad guy here and says yes they are
employees then there somebody's going to
have to pay and there's no premiums paid
for an employee right yeah so I
understand what you mean there's a
something to address potentially
something to address thank you I don't
want to be there representative
McKenzie the current uh workers
compensation system is kind of a no
fault system that you come into this
system that you are determined to be an
employee in the benefit system so is it
it it's is it your testimony that they
would be taken out of this kind of no
fault system and be put in some some
place where the burden now shifts to the
employee so you got an
RA that is maxed out gets hurt and now
it's their burden to prove that they
were actually employes that's that's
what your testimony is that is correct
that's our understanding of the language
as currently written so when we look at
the I think it's Section Five Section
Five of the proposed language it's
starting um at RSA 281
a26 I'm bad at Roman Neals uh B1 and
then it's talking about um it starts
with subject to the preceding paragraph
So the preceding paragraph is what sets
the tone for what makes an employee You'
got to have an implied oral or written
contract for hire and then you go down
to the section that they're amending
which says um you know except for the
following individuals which now that I
have it in front of me it's um real
estate brokers or agents or real estate
appraisers persons providing Services as
part of a residential placement for
individuals with developmental acquired
or emotional disabilities um who perform
services for pay for an employer and now
they're adding raas and dorm counselors
um who perform services for pay as an
for an employer is presumed to be an
employee so what that section would in
effect be doing is saying all
individuals are presumed to be employees
except for our direct sellers our
specified you know real estate
individuals our our residential
placement providers for folks with
specified disabilities and Ras and dorm
counsel so it would place the burden on
those individuals to prove that they are
that they are indeed employees if a
dispute
arose uh if in fact the uh the system
says that they are it's determined
they're not
employees is the remedy uh does that
relieve
the
um employer of that protection that they
currently have under the workers
compensation system where they cannot be
sued that's an excellent excellent
question and it's a little bit of a
nuanced one um I think it would really
depend on a lot of on a couple of
different factors it is a workers
compensation is a no fault system the
idea being that the workers compensation
system is there um to provide benefits
in in Bonafide um you know compensable
injur injury scenarios um and then
prevents employees from suing the
employer for tort or negligence or
anything else of that nature um that's
set forth at Section 8 whether or not
Section 8 applies can sometimes be a
somewhat complicated analysis you're
looking at whether or not you know the
injur the the claimed injurious event
and what you're trying to sue for are
are arising out of the same thing so it
it honestly could depend
um potentially um but it would be very
fact specific so it's it's uh obscure
enough that that we can't say we can't
say in this committee you can't say that
we are I don't want to put words in your
mouth but that that that would not be
the issue that would not be the
situation where people could be
employees could be exposing themselves
potentially they possibly could be I
think it would depend on this on each
individual scenario final question Mr
chairman if I could um if you take
somebody out of the definition of employ
how does it affect all the other
sections of the law we talked earlier
about posters and Y and all those kinds
of things there a whole lot of
protections that are built in for
employees within the law does this lift
all that off of the
uh that's also an excellent question um
so as far as protective legislation and
I'm doing it for memory but it's
amending the definitions at sections
four sections 36 and sections 42 I
believe I'll have to go back and double
check so I'll correct myself um perhaps
in writing if I'm if I'm wrong from
memory I believe that is all the
definitions of employee throughout the
statute so each each section of
protective legislation has its
definition section that then applies to
that to that section so you're
referencing um specifically
notifications and posters U yes the
protection wouldn't be there if the um
language went into effect because the
definition of what makes an employee at
would be amended to not include those
individuals as employees it does not um
take the responsibility away from the
employer as a whole from posting because
they're still going to have employees um
you know but if but the
protection whom it's serving they would
not be considered employees For Whom the
protection is there to serve so minimum
wage right the the requirements under
2791 um that's the only definition of
employee in RSA 279 which is the minimum
w age law they would be removed from the
definition um of employee for those uh
purposes um and again my understanding
is that somewhat the intent there um was
to kind of marry that up with how us do
is is looking at it under flsa um and
then there's also the workers
compensation piece thank you Mr chairman
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question I'd like to go
back to when Miss preventure was
testifying and we were talking about if
um nobody accepted this position as an
RA would they then have to go outside um
and there was I had a question regarding
um imputed income if if room was
provided to that person do you happen to
have an answer to that question can you
restate the question for me if you don't
mind the if they were to hire an outside
person instead of a student at the
school and they were required then to
provide this person with room
um would that would that um benefit of
having paid room be considered imputed
income would that be considered part of
their compensation package I mean I
realize that New Hampshire doesn't have
an income tax but and from the federal
government they would so would that be
considered part of an income
package I
think there are
certain it's a good question and I may I
may actually follow up with you in
writing to make certain you an accurate
answer because I would hate to misspeak
on the record and then have to clarify
later um if they're hiring someone from
outside of the University system you
don't have a student they wouldn't be
subject to the exemption um which means
that labor you know the remain labor
laws would apply um as specified for New
Hampshire um if living on campus was a
contingency of
employment
um I'd have to check to see whether or
not that would count as imputed income
and or I don't know that I don't believe
it could be deducted from minimum wage
because it's not one of the specific
areas specified by Statute where
providing room or Lodge um like I think
it's hotels and certain types restaurant
associations there's a specific section
that allows a a deduction um towards
meeting minimum wage but universities
are not one of those specified employers
um so perhaps I can get you a more exact
answer if that's okay and follow-up in
writing just to make certain that I
accurately answer your
question representative St
thank you um thank you for taking my
question I'd like to go back to the
situation that happened with pmth where
they provided an additional stien to Ras
and that put them over the line um you
said can you um tell me what how they
went over the line and what was the
problem there sure and and that may be
another one that was a case um I'm
familiar with it was a little bit before
my time in this position so I I don't
want to misstate EXA what happened so
while I'm aware of it I'm not intimately
familiar with all of the details of it
um my recollection and the case was a
little bit ago um my recollection was
there were one a complaint was received
within the department which was what in
you know instigated the inspection
process um the in the Department's
involvement um there were Ras in that
scenario if I'm remembering correctly um
who there was some kind of stien um
issue that they were post the stien
covered 20 hours or something of that
nature um but on inspection the
department uh had determined uh that the
students were working in excess of the
20 hours um my recollection is some 6050
some some hour in excess of that um and
on you know completed inspection our
determination was there was these were
employees and there was wages um that
that actually maybe let me get you a
good synopsis of that because I'm not
sure I'm remembering the outcome 100%
correctly from memory but there was um
there were some issues there with that
um setup which again I understand and we
understand from um hearing from the
University system was somewhat of the
impetus for why you know the express
need for the language and we do
understand um that Express need as it
relates to the proposal I mean again we
understand what's being Exempted out uh
both under protective legislation
minimum wage and workers compensation if
the language were to go into a effect as
written We believe We Could regulate
that um we would be able to you know to
to regulate that um but I can get you a
May perhaps a clear synopsis of what the
outcome of that or what the um sort of
scenario was with plym because I'm not
sure I I would be comfortable doing it
from memory can I ask one followup yeah
um would it in in some ways it seems
like you know you're addressing one
particular incident that happened it
seems like this is a lot of Overkill um
would it be possible to
um prevent this from happening in the
future by providing guidance from the
Department of Labor to the university
system rather than upending the whole um
College um ra uh program in the
state the department is always happy to
provide guidance I um we try incredibly
hard and I think we're successful uh in
being available to employers employees
um insurance carriers medical providers
any stakeholder who may have interaction
with our statutes um certainly in
whether this language goes into effect
or not if an employer to reach were to
reach out to us asking what's the status
of the law um you know can we tell them
specifically yes structure your business
this way to stay in compliance I I we're
not we're not really able to give
specific guidance um sometimes it's best
to consult with an attorney who knows
your business best in order to get that
kind of guidance but we can always walk
uh provide technical um guidance and
walk employers employees through what's
required by statutes that they have the
knowledge about what those stated
requirements are such that they can
craft their compliance um so I I'm not
certain that necessarily answers um the
question I I don't know that I know the
answer to that um but it is something
that we're available for in either
event representative
Sullivan thank you um just want want to
make sure I understand what you were um
indicating under section two the
discrimination in the workplace um if if
I got the two of you accurately
um removing the discrimination in the
workplace um uh
protection would allow um a college to
um potentially pay men and women
different amounts is that one of the uh
aspects I think um as attorney garrian
had tried to or had had very well
highlighted there are going to be two
components to discrimination that one
would need to bear in mind so as far as
the Discrimination Provisions that are
housed within the statutes overseen by
the Department of Labor it would remove
the Department's ability to um look at a
complaint were one to come in um from an
RA and say you're an employee for the
purposes of this discrimination section
relative to pay discrepancies um and
either you know make inspection findings
or facil there's a hearing process that
can be related to that and facilitate
that hearing process because they're not
going to meet the employee employee
employer relationship threshold to put
their foot in the door how the
anti-discrimination statutes overseen
through the Human Rights Commission at
354a which encompasses I believe gender
discrimination disability discrimination
and a host of other things I don't know
I don't I don't know how this would
impact
those sections um just not being that
versed in their statutes um and I don't
know that there would be interplay but
it would remove the prohibition in the
labor laws um for that type of that type
of action because you would not have the
requisite relationship um to trigger it
thank you representative
bani uh is there anybody else who has a
question question before before he
goes not at all I have plenty Mr go
ahead uh thank you Mr chairman and good
to see you Deputy Commissioner see you
as well um I have a few questions one is
uh the federal flsa defines Ras as
non-employees and they given employment
in kind would that be correct I heard um
the first half of the question that the
fsla does not define raas and employees
and their interpretation is in general
no employees are uh raas don't fall
within the category of employee I didn't
quite hear the whole question related to
in kind I'm sorry it's noisy um so
they're given employment in kind so
definition of in kind is benefits
outside of actual pay which is income um
the IRS looks at that as non- taxable
income for for the purposes of defining
an employee an employee only has to have
taxable income if there's no tax if an
Raa does not receive taxable income from
the University that does not define them
as an employee which is what the federal
law is done and I'm sure the IRS
probably weighed heavily in on that so
have a definition of how much room in
board is to an to a employee employed by
the school would probably turn the
university system upside down and having
to pay taxes wages and everything else
according to those
benefits I'm not sure I know um to be
honest it's one I I may need to look at
and try to follow up with you on um or
perhaps I don't know
if I know what that means um basically
it makes them a
volunteer for that position because
they're receiving St something in kind
in relations to a non-income entity
whether it be for some of them uh if
you're working a volunteer in a library
they might you might get to take free
books or if you volunteer in a hospital
you get a percentage you get a free meal
free lunch for the day or something so
there is something in kind for offering
employment in kind for hours work or
some type of thing work um follow follow
up thank you Mr chairman um under
workman's compensation do we still have
a casual employment
provision can you define casual
employment for me um let's say you have
a part-time employee that works once a
month that is not listed on your
workman's compensation or a volunteer
that happens to be in a hospital maybe
hurts their back moving a case or
something or something like that would
workman's compensation kick in on that
given that they're technically a casual
employee so if you're talking about a
volunteer in the sense that there's not
some kind of implied verbal some sort of
contract for hire you can have an
employee who works once a month once a
week but if they are falling within the
definition under workers compensation
even if it's casual work or very
infrequent work workers compensation may
still be at issue if it's a true
volunteer um you're not cross that
threshold you may not have the requisite
relationship um for the workers's
compensation statute to attach so follow
so if the Ra was injured in the course
of their duties they're still considered
a
volunteer still would still be
considered a volunteer and would have no
cause to show that they're an employee
injured in their duties because they're
employee employee in kind and are you
asking under the proposed language I'm
asking under our current language under
our current language um they would be
presumed to be an employee
because the workers compensation sector
is not necessarily looking at um the
type of payment that you're receiving
whether it's in kind or otherwise and
determining whether or not that employee
employer relationship is that issue so I
in a in under current scenario you could
you could and I've not seen it but you
could have uh an RA who asserts a claim
I got hurt I tripped on stairs or
whatever it may have been I broke up a
fight I I don't know what kind of
injuries um AR may be subject to but
under current varation of Statute they
very well could put a claim forward it
would go through the routine processes
the employer would be obligated to file
the first report notify their insurance
carrier the insurance carrier very well
may say um we don't believe that there's
an employer employer relationship there
we're denying the claim that would
trigger the dispute process that's set
forth under the workers compensation
statute where the language here would
really um takes the most effect uh the
proposed language would take the most
effect is that presumption of employment
no longer would attach and it would be
on the uh resident advisor to establish
that they're an employee for the
purposes of workers compensation
benefits thank you last followup oh um
so if they are technically not an
employee under federal law and they're
technically not an employee under this
change um and they're injured at work
would it be a liability issue for the
college to have insurance in place for
that like a private insurer it's an
excellent question and I actually would
defer maybe to the university system I'm
not that well versed in other forms of
liability I imagine it potentially could
be but I would defer to them to perhaps
answer that um again if it's not falling
within the realm as it relates to
providing for injuries if it's not going
to fall within the realm or you can't
establish uh under either proposed
language or current iteration of
language that there is that requisite
relationship such that workers
compensation is that issue um that begs
the question of what else may
potentially be there to either provide
benefits time out of work benefits
injury benefits Andor whether or not
dependent upon scenario you know the
specifics of the scenario whether or not
the um purported employer has any form
of liability for whatever incident
occurred thank you thank you
welcome there's additional question
yes but when we speak about the question
of volunteers there actually is um in
the law uh because I've run into it
doing events uh where there's a whole
section about volunteers and liability
and those kinds of things so we start
talking about that that's a whole
another dimension of uh yeah are you are
you referencing the um the firefighter
first not which um which section there
was a section there was a protection put
in at the federal level oh at the
federal level prot okay well no to
protect employees New Hampshire opted
out of that protect volunteers so we
have a separate section dealing with
volunteers within the law okay and I'd
have to dig it up again but okay but I
we've run into a couple events done
so are there any other questions for the
Departments um we did all get one more
uh card for speaking on this bill so um
thank you very much fortim thank you and
I'll call Janet schaer uh speaking in
opposition to the bill representing
herself
thanks good afternoon now um my name is
Jan schaer I uh live in Warner New
Hampshire I'm testifying um on my own
behalf um thank you for taking my late
testimony and it's going to be very
short
um I just wanted to call attention to um
the differences that the students at
Dartmouth described and the university
system described in how people are paid
so Dartmouth they get a stien but they
get a W2 UNH they don't um get a W2 and
they don't get a stipend and I I would
just ask the committee to really think
about all the different colleges and
universities who have raas around the
state how do they compensate them um
there may well be places that do an
hourly compensation and it would be
really good to know that before
proceeding um with this type of
legislation um and that is the entirety
of my testimony except the students from
Dartmouth asked me to apologize for
their leaving they had to go back to
work or to class but I said I would do
that for them all right thank you very
much thank you um
questions seeing none and that being the
final
card if there is no one to testify I
will close the hearing on HB 57
what why don't you speak
to well you're in charge of
anyone against subcommittee on this why
do we need one no against it no okay I'm
going to need two volunteers one from
each side uh so uh let me know um
please do you I do what do you want
done no we're way behind we've got this
bill go ahead keep going all
right so with that the uh the hearing on
5117 is closed and I will open the
hearing on S SP
330 and ask Senator Perkins Kula to
present the
bill good afternoon chair and members of
the
committee uh for the record I am Senator
Rebecca Perkins quoka I represent Senate
District 21 city of Portsmouth in the
towns of Durham Lee Madbury Newcastle
newfields Newington and new
market today I'm honored to introduced
SB 330 FN an act relative to allowing
the ability to work from home to count
towards employment unemployment benefits
eligibility I've worked closely with the
um New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security to craft the
language we bring before you today um a
recent study found that as of mid 2023
about 28% of working AED Americans spend
their entire workday at home since the
beginning of the Pandemic those numbers
have increased significantly and the
number of people working from home
continues to
rise more people are are able to find
work remotely and yet our state does not
have any flexibility or process to
protect this large number of people as
they um transition from One employment
opportunity to the next s sp330
recognizes This Modern it and
accommodates the different ways that
citizens can work by allowing um remote
work to to count towards continuing
eligibility for unemployment benefits so
the average um ter the average amount of
time our residents are on unemployment
is about a 10we period during that time
um if they want to continue to qualify
they need to continue to apply for jobs
and so we want um remote positions to be
one of the positions that that counts as
a job they're applying for right now the
statute as written provides no
flexibility to the Department of
Employment Security to make that
determination that it just prohibits
remote work from being considered so um
I'm hoping that you can be supportive of
this of this change which was s merely
give the department um the discretion to
allow those applications to count for
the continued eligibility when it makes
sense I've also you know been in
conversation with the Bia and New
Hampshire legal assistance on this bill
um it passed out of the Senate without
Amendment and I would be happy to answer
any questions that I can about it thank
you very much for your testimony I did
have a I have a question as I was
reviewing this language
um it makes sense to me and I have my
own idea of what terms like reasonable
expectation means um my my question and
maybe this came from the Senate review
of it is we're placing all that on the
department to define the details and
rules
um why not be more specific in the
legislative language and
intent so that we know that we're what
we're passing is in sync with what we
mean and what the department will do
sure thank you so much for the question
I I welcome the Department's input on
this but as the policy makers I think
part of the challenge is that we do want
to make sure um those applying for
unemployment benefits are seeking all
opportunities for work and I think
that's probably something um everyone
involved in this issue agrees on and so
different different folks applying for
benefits have different situations and I
think there just does need to be some
degree of discretion for the Department
to be interacting with these applicants
and and determining in each case that
they are making every effort to be of
available for
employment thank you um other questions
representative
McKenzie
than good how are you
representative why why don't you put on
your microphone
thanks leave it
Al uh so when you you list
home uh there are many people work
remotely that don't necessarily work at
their home there is a whole new
environment out there where you drop in
grab a desk and so I just don't I just
want to make sure that we're not putting
ourselves in a position where it's just
H work where it's it's remote work I
guess um and opportunities for remote
work which could take place all over
many different areas it's it's a good
point representative um and I think that
the idea is to capture um remote work
I'll let the department speak to it
because um this may just correspond to
the way they classify it in their rules
and application in which case I wouldn't
want to deviate from it but we we share
the
intent thank you thank you other
questions representative
infon thank
you I'm trying to figure out what your
goal is here because obviously we need
people to be available MH to go back to
work mhm in order to stay on
unemployment we have Curves in our
system so if someone decides to go to
the Caribbean for two weeks and they log
on to say Hey you know I'm looking for
my employment benefits and the system
now knows no you are not available for
work you were on vacation somewhere so
you weren't available for work so you're
not entitled to benefits that week so if
someone is working at
home because that's what their current
job allows them to do MH and they are to
lose that
job is it your intent that they should
be able to collect
unemployment until they find another job
in their home to be consistent with what
they had before or what happens if
another job comes up of the
same same type and they say no we
require you to be in the office five
days a week
so I'm trying to understand what you're
trying to do
here yes thank you chair thank you for
the question so the intent is not that
the applicant can only apply for remote
work positions but that the department
have the flexibility to allow for remote
applications to be considered for that
continuing eligibility so again the you
know the department would be in touch
with the applicant but it is the
applicant is not permitted and wouldn't
be permitted under this language to only
apply for remote positions but rather
for those remote positions to be
included amongst the applications that
they're
making thank you that address it okay
yes thank you representative alalani Noe
that was that was it all right any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your thank you so much
committee and at this point I oh here it
comes
who's on this
bill uh so we have the bill one of the
Bill's co-sponsors representative kahill
speak Bill thank you Mr chair and as you
not that I am a co-sponsor so I did not
feel it appropriate to ask my Senator a
question so but I did want to bring
forward the point that yeah the the uh
Department's rule is that uh you know
Hess is Curr currently not eligible if
you are working from home and that's
what the bill would
change
um would you believe that you know my
daughter is working in a software
company and her colleagues are from
Florida Montana they they they they
advertise in several States uh New
Hampshire is fortunately one of them but
very very few people actually come into
the office so I think if one of those
persons was to lose it be laid off or
lose the job or move on to another place
unemployment should certainly take into
account that they might still be looking
for uh a work at home situation and
especially they may have child care as
part of their incentive to work from
home and and feed that baby now and then
um so it's certainly an option that's
more available than it was when I was in
the workforce and we want to encourage
that to happen all right thank you very
much questions
seeing none thank you again thank you
and while you were speaking I got some
additional cards so I would ask Joy
Kurt um speaking in support of the bill
to come
forward this okay is that better yeah
okay uh my name is Joy Kur I am going to
share my story I'm the one that
advocated to senator quac Perkins for
this bill uh cuz I
experienced uh the adverse side of this
bill affecting me I am a VP of
technology and was working for as sendal
which is a company based at Hampton New
Hampshire that is 100% remote uh they
employee people in New Hampshire and all
over the United States and the state of
New Hampshire requires them to pay
unemployment for all employees including
myself I was laid off in October 2020 uh
22 and I I was actually hired my mom
lives in San Diego and while I was
living in San Diego even though my
residence is in Portsmouth and I live
here a majority of the year and so I was
able this is my longer version of the
story but I think it's relevant because
it covers a couple points so I went to
the unemployment office uh while I was
collecting unemployment and I used to
work it into it which is first St of San
Diego to meet with former colleagues to
pursue other opportunities so I went to
the unemployment office and asked am I
allowed to go to San Diego so just
because someone's not in New Hampshire
doesn't mean they're actively on
vacation they might be exploring other
opportunities that are remote to remain
in New Hampshire and I was given the yes
you're able to go the day I was left uh
a week later I got declined
unemployment even though I had been
collecting for five weeks and I'll share
this as well I also own a retail
business in Portsmouth New Hampshire and
I'm a little bit of a very unique
situation that I employ two to three to
10 people at a time and and there's
another bill that I think needs to be
made which is I was informed that I
could not collect unemployment and keep
this business open effectively because
even though I survived covid and kept
the business open I've been open for
seven years because this unemployment
does not
recognize expenses like the IRS does so
if I made $100 in a winter day but my
employee expenses are 150 I have to
report $100 of income on my un
employment so that put me in a position
that I ended up having to lay off all my
staff in January of 2022 so I did that
go to California to expand my
opportunity for the first time I had to
lay people off in spite of Co and
keeping everybody employed and then I
get declined you call unemployment they
told me it was because of the law so I
presumed it was because I was in
California and appealed it it takes
about seven weeks to get an
appeal uh and also I'll share this when
you go through Unemployment you have to
fill out a questionnaire every week
there's about 20 questions there is
nothing about applying for remote work
as disqualifying you they require you
for you to apply for five jobs there's
nothing saying is one of those jobs or
all of those jobs B said in New
Hampshire uh it's here's the five jobs
and I was logging those I also
previously was exploring an opportunity
in Boston but in this period of time the
jobs I applied for is remote I work in
Tech almost a m it's shifting a little
bit now but in 2022 23 still a
significant amount of opportunities are
remote at this point from Co and the
workforce shifting so it took seven
weeks to get an appeal to find out why I
was being declined I've now closed my
business I accelerated it and finally
five weeks later I end up on the appeal
hearing and we're answering and I was
speaking in the context of I'm applying
for remote work I'm in California
thinking I was being decent because I
was in California and networking there
and applying for for jobs and in the
middle of the hearing I got informed it
was because I wasn't available for work
outside of my home by applying for work
it actually had nothing to do with being
in California this was the first time I
find out about this five weeks after um
and I got declined for five weeks of
unemployment in spite of laying off all
my employees so this is why I've
advocated for this bill uh I'll also
share that technically I own a
commercial property I live upstairs on
the second floor my first floor by law
and
um zoning in Portsmouth must be retail
and I have an office in there and yet I
was considered working from home because
I have the same business address as my
upstairs address so I'll also just share
my opinion on this um the other thing to
consider besides the fact oh I'm now or
actually currently offered a role it's
100% remote based out of California out
of San CL out of my network so I think
this law is incredibly Antiquated and we
also need to to recognize that when
people are expanding their job search
that that opens them up to more
opportunities versus saying the only
option I have is liy mutual which I
applied for a job in my time that I was
laid off I worked there for 11 years I
was one of 400 applicants and the hiring
manager had to pull my name out of the
bin because 400 people including people
not in New Hampshire can now apply for
jobs at liing Mutual elector and so
people outside of New Hampshire are now
competing for jobs that they don't have
to drive down the street like I used to
do two miles away from my home so we're
actually limiting people's ability to
find work and collect unemployment which
I've lived in New Hampshire since I was
5 years old was incredibly disappointing
to me as someone that felt like my
company paid into it I'm an employer I
play into unemployment there's this
perception of if you're expanding your
work you're just trying to like kick
back and drink a capan of clot in the
Caribbean but it's not the situation um
and if we do keep this law or I mean I
think it's I hope that it's pretty
obvious this needs to be change but if
not it also needs to be clear in the
application and actually the other thing
I'll say is I called the unemployment
office many times while this was going
on and after the fact none of the
employees knew that this was a law so
that's how I ended up in this appeal
meeting and kind of got backed into a
corner and got declined unemployment for
five weeks after I shut down my business
to collect uny employment that is my
story thank you thank you for listening
are there
questions
that I heard two different things I I
need to sure understand were you denied
yes because well could you sum could you
summarize why you denied because I'm
hearing one thing about owning your own
business MH and not being able to apply
versus the remote aspect of it after I
initially was declined and what was the
initial decline for for having a
business you can't collect unemployment
be self-employed I don't I'm not a W2 my
employee is not my livelihood it's a
hobby business there is a provision that
you can have a hobby business and still
collect unemployment my livelihood I
cannot live off of the business it is
not um part of why I keep employees on
in the winter I am literally in that
example you know Portsmouth it's the
street with the tug boats it's like a
wind tunnel I don't like to lose my
employees I lost one of my best
employees in this matter um but I keep
them on and some days on blizzard days
pay their employee wages out of my own
personal income like I probably should
sometimes not not be open but I do it to
keep staff I do it to keep them employed
and so in that scenario so I then got um
after my initial decline I was approved
because it was recognized that this is a
ho this is supplemental income I think
is what it's called um my income is my
Tech
Career okay so that was the first right
that's not why we're here yeah okay and
then explain what happened on the the
second the second one was that I then
was collecting for four or five weeks or
whatever it was maybe eight and I asked
if I could go to California to pursue
work there and I was given a yes A week
later
I got
declined and go to California travel
live there move there no my mom lives
there to pursue opportunities there my
my address is New Hampshire I still on
my house my cars are here I went there
shortterm to pursue opportunities
because I used to live and work there
for five years okay and interview there
so and you were still pursuing
opportunities there corre so why was
that declin because I found out in the
appeal meeting that I the applications I
submit in that period of time were for
remote work because I work in technology
and there's a significant amount of work
so that's what we're talking about I
found out in the appeal meeting that I
was declined because I was applying for
working at home which is also a little
Nuance for me specifically because my
office is in the same address as my
business so I think I shouldn't have
been declined at all but this raised the
issue of this law is Antiquated anyone
that works in technology and I'm an
example had a completely remote job
State of New Hampshire requires that
company to pay unemployment for me the
2.9% or whatever it is I am now going to
be employed again with a fully remote
job based out of New Hampshire I mean
based out of California but living in my
exact same residence and work fully
remote all and if I was limited to
applying for jobs in New Hampshire he
would actually be detrimental to my job
search because 400 people are applying
for jobs at Liberty Mutual because
they're they're offering it to remote
people that used to only be remote all
right thank you for the clarification
yeah thank you representative Vine yeah
uh thank you Mr chairman just to dve
tail off of uh the Chairman's question
um when you got the yes did you get that
yes in writing or you just called it and
got a blanket yes because that would
probably be material to your appeals but
I didn't get to climb for that I got to
climb because I was applying for remote
work it had nothing to do with
California understood thank you yeah I
think my opin my belief about what
happened is the person declined me
because I was in California and the
person that I had the appe have had a
different interpretation of this law and
why I was declined thank you but this
should be removed altogether because
remote work is a common I don't know
what the numbers are but a majority I
mean every employee here work from home
during covid right like we all work from
home and can work from home and I think
this was a law was passed I think in '
84 87 or something there was probably a
time where it was perceived that if
you're working from home you're limiting
your opportunities and that is not the
current modern state of our society and
economy you actually are significantly
expanding your opportunities and telling
me to limit it to New Hampshire you're
actually causing me to maybe limit my
opportunities and be a New Hampshire
resident and actually me having a job
based out of California is and keeping
my business open is continuing the New
Hampshire economy and so this shouldn't
be the situation especially when I laid
off all my staff to collect
unemployment further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for
next I would call Steven Tower uh
representing New Hampshire Legal
Assistant speaking in support of the
bill uh good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm Steve Tower
I'm an attorney at New Hampshire legal
assistants um we represent low-income
families and seniors and I'm am one of
our attorneys that does a lot of our
unemployment work um I I will say that
the issue that this bill addressed you
know I've been at nhla doing
unemployment work since 2015
and it it I only realized that this was
an issue last fall I had a client last
fall who um had worked for a company for
I think eight or nine years and for the
last four or so years she had been
working remotely from home and part of
the reason that she had made that change
was um her mother had some health issues
and being in the home with her mother
during the workday allowed her mother to
remain at home and not in a nursing home
home and the employer was happy to do
that she was eventually laid off and she
went to apply for unemployment and was
denied and she applied for assistance
with us now I don't deal with a lot of
people who work remotely because we
represent primarily low-income workers
um but at this point she was unemployed
and had no income so she was low income
and that's how she ended up in our
office um and through the appeal process
I quickly discovered that there is an
existing section in RSA 282 a um the
unemployment statute that talks about um
uh that an individual who is only
available for work inside the home is uh
ineligible for unemployment and one of
the questions that she was asked during
her questionnaires for her application
was are you available for work outside
the home and she had said no and she was
denied for that purpose so I had to tell
her unfortunately as the Law's written
you're not eligible for unemployment now
she did find another um work from home
job about 8 weeks later that she started
and she's still working there um but she
was not eligible for unemployment for
those two months that she was out of
work because she was looking at
exclusively remote work jobs um and uh
then I saw that this bill was was
introduced and and I wanted to to speak
to it a little bit um before I forget uh
representative McKenzie you had a
question earlier about why it says
specifically home and that there are you
know cafes that people work from and
such and and I believe the reason the
bill is written this way is because the
original um 282a col 39 was specifically
restricted eligibility for people who
were only available to work at home and
in the 80s I imagine that was primarily
people who might have been doing um
telemarketing or peac meal working of
producing something in their home you
know a fairly limited section of the
workforce and of course not everyone in
New Hampshire's Workforce can work from
home restaurant workers construction
workers anyone that that has to go out
and deal with the public they they're
not able to do that from home but there
is a very substantial section of the
workforce office workers that are now
able to work from home um and this bill
would uh allow them to uh work from home
and continue looking for work from home
so long as they have a reasonable
expectation of finding that job now um I
wouldn't be able to to to limit my work
search from home because I'm an attorney
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to go to court
I'm gonna have to come to legislative
hearings I would not be able to find a
job like this if I were limiting myself
to uh work from home so uh but there are
many people who are able to um both of
my parents who live in Massachusetts uh
work from home my mother has worked from
home for the last 20 years um as a
office manager for book Manufacturing
Company um I recently moved up to
Thorton in Grafton County and I've met a
number of people who have moved up to
the northern Tri Counties um who are
able to work remotely um and and they
are now able to live in places working
for uh larger companies that maybe don't
have physical locations in those
counties and now
they are able to bring that money and
their families into those
communities um I I see this change as
being a major benefit to New Hampshire's
economy and
allowing uh New Hampshire to compete
with the growing remote Workforce to
bring that money and those employees
here to the state of New Hampshire um
and I uh I while it does not directly
affect a large portion of my client base
at nhla it does affect some of them um
so I am in support of this bill and I
was also involved in the discussions
with Senator Perkins quara and the the
Bia to
um discuss any concerns that the Bia had
about this bill and um I think I I I
hope that this committee uh uh supports
this Bill thank you thank you very much
are there questions represent Susi
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the
question do people working from home
have a reasonable expectation of
substantial
opportunities uh it depends on what type
of work they do if they're a
construction worker I would say that
they're probably not going to have a
reasonable opportunity of finding
construction work from their their home
office um but um so that that
calculation is going to be made by the
department and the department already
makes similar calculations
for the work search requirement that
already exists in
um if I were to become unemployed today
I initially could be limiting my work
search to other attorney positions in
the state of New Hampshire I wouldn't
immediately have to apply for a fast
food position or um um you know a
janitorial position or or something that
would not make the best use of my skill
set um and
as the department assesses my my skill
set and the availability for work with
what I'm looking for out there they can
require me to start looking outside of
my most recent past work if my
unemployment drags on or uh the there
are not a substantial number of attorney
positions available in New Hampshire at
the time and so the department makes
that calculation about um the reasonable
expectation of of acquiring work with
the work search as the time goes on for
the number of weeks that people are are
receiving
benefits representative
Schultz no Oh I thought you had your
hand up representative
s yeah you provided an explanation for
why uh the work from home terminology is
in here um do you feel that it there
would be benefit in rewarding this so
that um rather than work from home the
remote work um uh terminology was
used
so and and this might be a question
better answered by the department but as
I read RSA 282a col 39 um as it
currently exists not the proposed
amendment if someone were asked are you
available for work outside the home and
uh you know they were willing to work
remotely from a you know a shared
workspace or something like
that I I think if they said they were
available for work outside the home that
would not be a dishonest statement to
the department and based on this section
of the law they already would be
eligible for benefits and the department
can correct me if I'm wrong um my client
ran into an issue because they
specifically said that they would be
doing their remote work from their home
and and this statute prohibits that so
um
perhaps there could be
um language could be included to clarify
that about remote remote work generally
um but um I don't I don't believe it is
an issue that would deny people benefits
if they were available to work from you
know um like a we work shared workspace
or something like that just uh quick
quick follow up the um if we change it
to remote work we might actually um
disqualify more people is that
accurate I we don't want to do that if
if this amendment as proposed in this
bill were not adapted adopted but the
the language in in col 39 were to say an
individual shall not be eligible for
benefits in any week during which the
individual is um only available for
remote work or or is available for
remote work but other work as well um
that could be a problem but I I I think
if the bill were adopted as it is no
change to the language about remote work
would be necessary in the bill
language representative
alalani thank you Mr chairman um can you
define substantial employment
opportunities
um well uh that the department defines
it as is often the case with agencies
that enforce uh laws like this they will
uh make an assessment based on
the uh the number of job opportunities
that are available in the in the state
economy okay I I can't uh Define that
specifically the department would be the
the experts on how that is assessed and
implemented by the department and follow
oh follow shouldn't it be defined here
for um ease of your
job um well if if I were working with a
client who were denied under this
provision on the basis that the
department took the position that there
were not substantial um reasonably
likelihood of uh substantial employment
opportunities um at a hearing I would be
able to uh dispute that finding by the
department with the demonstration that
the my client has found opportunities
that they would be able to work and that
they did apply to them and uh that uh
there were
a a a substantial quantity of
opportunities that uh the client had a a
likelihood of obtaining one of them um
now if there's five jobs in the state
that they could have applied to uh I
think I would have a very hard time
convincing an appeal tribunal
chairperson that that constitutes a
reasonable likelihood of my client
obtaining one of those five jobs but if
I can show that there's hundreds of
remote work jobs that the client would
have been eligible for I think it's a
pretty easy win for me um I I don't feel
comfortable putting a a number
requirement on how many jobs have to be
out there for it to be be reasonable in
the statute because I think the
reasonable
expectation will vary depending on the
economic status of the state at any
given time um reasonable likelihood of
employment say in 2009 in a particular
field might be different than today just
based on the number of people who are
also looking for work thank you thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony and I have one
final card on this bill from New
Hampshire employment security uh Karen
levchuk um the department is neither in
support nor in opposition to the
bill he's on vacation
I'll start again um good afternoon I'm
Karen lovchuk I'm general counsel for
New Hampshire employment security um and
I'm here today just to answer any
questions you may have and I can give a
a very brief overview if you'd like as I
get started thank you um I think it
might be helpful just to review the
original language um because it's hard
to read it through the the strikeouts on
on the copy that's available uh for
Senate Bill 330 um 282 a39 is entitled
unavailable for work and it currently
provides that an individual shall be
disqualified for benefits for any week
or weeks any part of which he is not
available for work outside of a home
irrespective of his reason for refusing
to be available for work outside of a
home um and so the language as amended
would Now read it would still
still be entitled unavailable for work
but the language would Now read um an
individual shall not be eligible for
benefits for any week or weeks during
any part of which the individual is not
available for work outside of the
individual's home unless work to be
conducted within the individual's home
offers a reasonable expectation of
substantial employment opportunities
based upon rules adopted by the
commissioner pursuant to 541 RSA 541a
so um the statute is something that we
really hadn't seen a lot of um issues
come up um until more recently and most
likely that is because during the
pandemic there was a great increase um
in individuals engaging in remote work
and so for the first time the department
was getting more claims from people who
were separated from remote work um and
potentially engaging in work searches
that were f focused on remote work as
opposed to a general work search um
which would include both in-person and
remote work
opportunities and I believe um when
Deputy Commissioner lers testified at
the Senate um hearing on this matter he
talked about the fact that that
determinations on unemployment
compensation benefits are made on a week
by- week basis and so if someone was
working remotely and they lost their job
and they applied for benefits in the
first week it may not be a problem they
may have they may have originally been
found eligible in the first week just
based upon the nature of their
separation but the problem would then
revolve around continued eligibility and
so the individual has to show that they
are available for work and adequately
participating in the labor market so in
other words they're not unduly
restricting their search for work and
that's a very important component of the
unemployment system um so just moving
from there and talking more about the
specifics
um of of our review of this bill and I
will be very sad if I've lost my
notes there we go
um so the bill has been amended by
specifically referencing the
individual's home as has been pointed
out by removing the requirement to
disregard the individual's reason for
not being available to work outside a
home by permitting an individual who's
not available for work outside the
individual's home to be eligible for
benefits if the work to be conducted
within the home offers a reasonable
expectation of substantial employment
opportunities and the law also requires
the commissioner to adopt rules
establishing criteria for determining
whether work to be conducted within the
individual's home offers that reasonable
expectation of substantial uh employment
opportunities um as we always do the
department reached out to the US
Department of Labor to see if the law as
amended would be in Conformity with
Federal requirements for state
unemployment programs and those most of
those Conformity requirements arise out
of this Social Security Act um and we
did receive feedback um substantive
feedback from the US Department of Labor
um the the US Department of Labor
informed us that the bill as written
would not create a Conformity issue but
that there was substantial concern about
individuals maintaining an attachment to
the labor Market um and so what what the
US Department of Labor um outlined in a
letter was that New Hampshire uh can go
did you hold for a moment did everyone
receive the notice from representative
uh from Richard lver that she's talking
about
okay okay I know should we Brian and I
received it I thought everyone had
received it I'll make sure everyone has
it but go ahead okay thank you Mr chair
um essentially there were four
components uh to the Department's
concerns um what they said is that New
Hampshire will need to evaluate on
individual claimants on a case-by Case
basis whether a the claimant Works in an
occupation for which remote work is
available in the labor market B has
previously performed remote work or
demonstrates a current capacity to be
able to do so um C has the necessary
tools and equipment to perform such work
and the claimant must further
demonstrate that they are actively
seeking such work during each week week
that benefits are um are claimed and
they have also the Department of Labor
has has offered to be available to
assist the department in
in writing rules which would then be
taken to the Joint Committee on um
administrative rulem at the legislature
uh to ensure that we cover those topics
to be sure that we stay in Conformity um
and again the general requirements for
eligibility for unemployment benefits
will not change as a result in the
change in the law an individual still
would have to be able and available to
work um and actively seek work um
and there is a component of this that
attorney Tower referred to which is the
work has to be or will be suitable work
so you don't if you're you know you're
not expected to take any job that comes
along there's a suitability aspect to it
which would look at the Education and
Training of the individual commuting
distance and also previous work history
so so the law as as amended um would be
governed by rules that would be adopted
by the department that would help the
department in each individual case
determine whether um the reasonable
expectation of substantial employment is
there in that individual case and that's
that's really all I have all right thank
you are there
questions representative
alalani thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for thank you for taking the
question
[Music]
um given the fact that a lot of the work
from home people shifted out of in place
employment um would a look back on the
department on their previous education
history work history everything else so
if they left Hospitality went into they
say tech support and then lost their job
in tech support would they be forced to
go back to hospitality or would they be
able to stay within the confines of tax
support or some type of other work from
home requirement instead of being forced
back to um an in-person
job I don't think they would be forced
back to a service sector job um we could
look at the industry we would look at
the industry in which the individual is
currently working we would look at what
concentration of remote work was
available in that industry I think
that's a very important part of the
equation I mean some Industries lend
themselves to remote work some don't so
that would be part of it um you know
again some of the other issues that go
to suitability don't really fit this but
I think the department of of Labor um
talked about whether there was any
previous performance of remote work
that's not all of the that's not the
entire test that's just part of it um
whether the industry lends itself to it
and also whether the individual has
necessary tools and is able to conduct
the work at home and that can all be um
that can all be uh ascertained through
asking the right questions when
somebody's applying for work or applying
for
benefits thank you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you and
that was the final card that I had on
this um on this bill we did mention at
the beginning that we were establishing
a
subcommittee for this
one did you have a conversation that I
don't know about
and maybe
um well all right
let if you need to go I was just in a
committee testifying there were four
people there okay I understand a lot of
people are on vacation and you may be
hungry or thirsty I have you have one
bill left and we have a small exec which
is I think we all know where it's going
to go if you would like to step out and
go get something to drink or eat that's
fine okay I understand I'm sorry but uh
we're going to try to keep with what
schedule we have here so I'll close the
hearing on it on S sp330 thank you and
we'll discuss subcommittee when you and
I have a chance to
talk um the last I'm sorry is the
executing right after this bill this
bill's hearing
yes it's it's scheduled for
1:30
um okay all right I'm opening the last
hearing on Senate Bill 350 calling
Senator Susi to uh introduce the Bill
thank you Senator nice seeing you thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
for the record I'm Donna Susi
representing Senate District 18 the town
of Lichfield and five boards in the city
of Manchester and I truly hate to come
between you and lunch so I will be as
succinct as possible um and I certainly
take no offense if anyone needs to leave
the
room um Senate Bill 350 is something
that is a continuation of a process um
for many years we've been studying the
effects of chemicals such as p in this
legislature um and this issue has become
particularly important in the workplace
for firefighters in particular um for
firefighters exposures um are like pasas
on steroids because not only are they
experiencing conditions um when
combating fires where they're
encountering things that are burning and
emitting chemicals um but we've now come
to the realization that the very gear
they wear to protect themselves also
emits chemicals um for those reasons
this legislature um and because these
chemicals have led to the early
detection of cancers uh this legislature
and its wisdom previously has shifted
the burden for workers compensation
claims um for particular cancers so that
no longer does the employee have to um
prove that it's work-related it's now
the burden shifted to the employer and
that's the primacia presumption what
this bill does is to ensure that there
isn't a gap in the coverage of health
insurance during a pendency of appeal
the reason for this is that although
we've shifted the burden as they said
the detection of these cancers is
happening at younger in younger and
younger um firefighters so as a result
many of these
individuals do not have a lot of leave
time because they're not afforded a lot
of leave time when they first start on
the job someone could be two or three
years on the job and be diagnosed with a
significant cancer um that they then um
file a worker's compensation claim
for and although a lot of these claims
are granted in some instances they're
not they're not granted right away so
what's happened in a few instances and
you will hear some other testimony which
I also think will be succinct is that
the employer is stuck with the problem
of an employee who has had a cancer
diagnosed they were on the job there's a
presumption that it occurred on the job
but because there isn't adequate leave
time if this person isn't able to work
it means that they could lose their job
and hence not have any coverage so what
the bill attempts to do is to fill in
that Gap during the pendency of appeal
now I recognize there is a cost to doing
that so so there are some guard rails
that the bill attempts to attach to try
to minimize that as much as possible um
one is that the period of time can't
last more than 18 months which is like
the period of time someone could Cobra
when they leave employment and it only
would apply to single coverage so if
someone had a family plan the employer
would not have to continue to cover the
whole family but would continue to cover
the individual the reason for this once
again is that if somebody is in the
midst of of receiving treatment um it
could be life-saving and we just don't
want that Gap to appear we believe the
numbers of these cases will be very few
as there are very few of them being
denied um in the population and there is
an attorney here who is a practitioner
specifically in workers comp for these
individuals who would be able to answer
more questions so with that I'd conclude
my testimony and I'd be happy to take
any questions
representative Broody thank you Mr
chairman thank you Senator you said
that it's very important not to have the
Gap because it could be life-threatening
for the employer
employee but it's not going to cover the
family correct it could
be it could be harmful for the family if
they needed it well thank you
representative there could be obviously
finan cial impacts to the family but I
think the legislation was crafted in um
a way to try to mitigate the cost and to
D to deal with the direct problem which
is the individual's own
health okay I understand to the extent I
mean to the extent the committee wants
to expand it but in the Senate our
belief was that coverage for that
individual and for their health care was
what was most critical was that brought
up in the Senate um it was not we
brought the bill in as a
single policy so if we put an amendment
on it's something they haven't seen over
there correct thank
you
McKenzie put
a i no in the cost estimates there's
nothing listed under the cost estimates
and what was the Senate's position on on
that so this bill first went to the
Senate health committee where the policy
was considered it was then referred to
the finance committee um and the belief
is that these cases are
few um they're rare so we do not know
the number but we believe that the
impact would be minimal um so it passed
the finance committee unanimously and
then was unanimous ly passed on a Voice
vote by the Senate further quick
followup Mr chairman uh were there any
objections filed by minicipal
association or any other organizations
Rel to this they did not okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman you're welcome I
have two uh questions for you Senator
first um I know we've only had the law
in place for two years or so so at this
point we have had no cases that are at
appeal the best of your knowledge you
know I I can't answer that directly Mr
chair I believe we have but I I believe
that they will um the testimony
following mine um testifiers would be
able to answer that question okay and
secondly um lines 11 through 13 you talk
about uh if if the employee is is
eligible employment for period of uh
benefits for 20-year period beginning
the effective date of the separation I I
question why you use that um I would
think someone who's let's say
55 um you know at 67 or whatever you
know Medicare would come in um so that
might be too much there on the other
hand if someone has this happened at 30
20 years isn't going to be enough
because they're still at 50 and they're
still not to Medicare age was there any
thought um to tying anything to benefits
through the
Medicare so um no there wasn't any
discussion regarding Medicare um I would
point so the section in the statute
dealing with heart lung or cancer is RSA
281a colon
17 and in that we do deal with retired
firefighters at uh Roman
2 number a number two B so retired
fighter fighters who have been retired
between 6 and 20 years who guarantees
that he or she has lived a tobacc free
lifestyle and who's receiving a pension
shall be eligible for medical payments
only under this section so that's where
it comes from it's part of the existing
statute and that's why it was carried
forward in this piece understood thank
you any other questions for the senator
for Senator
solivan I guess some little bit confused
that you know it says that the employee
shall be eligible for this benefit
starting at the beginning of his or her
employment in for a period of 20 years
from the effective date of Separation
but this benefit is um extending
employer-based health insurance if the
person has U left
employment 5 10 15 20 years
ago they they wouldn't still be getting
the employment based health
insurance right wouldn't be getting the
employer-based health insurance but they
still could have a claim under the
statute so what what this is dealing
with is the gap so I would argue that
someone who is retired wouldn't have
necessarily have that Gap it is possible
but um would probably be covered at that
point by either Medicare or their
retiree health benefit that they would
have received upon retirement
so this might not really apply but it
doesn't do any harm either I don't
believe it's doing any harm
representative you know further
questions thank you very much thank you
Mr
chairman calling Jerry Jeremy
llant welcome
uh good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Jeremy llant and I'm a lieutenant
with the Keen fire department having
served my community for the last 15
years I stand before you today to
strongly advocate for Senate Bill 350
which seeks to bridge a critical Gap in
health insurance coverage for emergency
response and Public Safety workers
facing a prima face or presumptive
conditions every day firefighters across
State put their lives on the line to
protect our communities recognizing the
inherent risks New Hampshire law
provides a prima face or presumptive
coverage for us however there remains a
significant Gap currently if a
firefighter is undergoing medical
treatment and then loses their job due
to the injury or illness and their
workers's compensation claim was denied
they face a precarious situation lacking
health insurance during a critical time
as a veteran firefighter I have used my
sick leave for various reasons including
covid-19 work rated injuries to my foot
and shoulder and family emergencies
specifically the premature birth of my
son I currently have about 12 weeks of
sick leave
accured but what happens if I or any
firefighter face a serious health issue
and our compensation claim is denied
this is not a hypothetical situation it
is a reality we live with every day we
are then forced to exhaust our sick and
vacation leave and once that's depleted
the Family and Medical Leave Act only
protects our employment for 12 weeks
after that we are left without income
and critically without health
insurance what does this difference in
coverage look like for a family uh few
weeks ago I spoke with a colleague who
was just diagnosed with stage four
prostate cancer one medication needed
for one month to treat his cancer is
$113,000 luckily with his health
insurance he's only responsible for a
$40
co-pay consider some other potential but
very realistic scenarios a newly hired
conquered firefighter paramedic on their
first day responds to an active shooter
incident the trauma experienced physical
emotional psychological is immense it
may take time to rehabilitate after such
an event if this firefighter's
compensation claim is denied they may
face not just the daunting recovery but
also the loss of health insurance with
no acude sick or vacation leave to fall
back on similarly a few years ago a
Manchester firefighter suffered a
cardiac arrest while fighting a fire
situations like these underscore the
unpredictability and IM immediacy of the
risk we
Face Senate Bill 350 directly addresses
these situations it ensures that while a
workers compensation claim is under
appeal for a presumptive injury the
affected emergency respond retains their
single person HealthCare coverage this
bill isn't just about sustained income
it's about ensuring that during the most
vulnerable times our firefighters aren't
burdened with the added stress of having
to pay for their immediate Medical
Treatments
no firefighter should face The Haunting
uncertainty of standing at the brink of
unemployment with their sole option
being to pay out of pocket for their
next mental health session cardiac
Rehabilitation or cancer treatment all
while their workers compensation claim
for a presumptive condition is pening
appeal in conclusion I urge you esteemed
members of the committee to support
Senate Bill 350 this bill is not just a
piece of legislation it's a safety net
for those who dedicate their lives to
serving and protecting our communities I
cannot stress enough the peace of mind
and security this bill will provide our
emergency responders thank you for your
time and consideration and I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have
representative Bui thank you Mr chairman
um uh thank you for your testimony and
uh taking my question do you know what
the average Premium cost would be for a
family instead of a single person no sir
I do not have that
information follow
um would you mind sharing what your
premium
is you don't have I mean that's personal
but just to give us an idea of what it's
going to cost for extra few
months um I I don't I don't know enough
about the I guess that difference to
really uh understand so using my my
colleague's example right that what I
what I am aware of is that difference in
cost between paying out of pocket versus
a a co-pay um so and then within each
really I guess across the state too
there's that difference of what is
employer versus employee cost which is
negotiated um at least for us so thank
you thank you any other questions for
the
presenter representative
McKenzie so the uh the amount of time it
takes to get through the process in New
Hampshire the unemploy the workers
compensation
process um are you familiar that
is dramatically reduced in comparison to
other states so if you're looking at the
potential cost for this over a period of
time realize that New Hampshire can get
through the process of appeals uh much
quicker than Massachusetts or other
states around the country so that would
limit the responsibility and the cost as
well uh would you believe would you
believe go thank you uh I I would would
believe and the language as uh Senator
sus uh explained that those guard rails
that have been placed on the 18 months
um certainly are there to also uh limit
those costs uh what's uh that 12we Mark
though was important and that there's no
more job guarantee after that if you're
out of leave and I've seen firsthand um
people that are struggling uh with what
they're going to do when they run out of
sick sick or vacation time and how
they're going to pay for their
payments thank you than
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much thank you Mr
chair I next call um John mallister
please good afternoon chairman infantine
and The Honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is John
mallister I'm a 25 year member of the
National Fire Department and I currently
serve as a secretary treasur for the
professional firef of New Hampshire I'm
here today to speak in full support of
Senate Bill
350 one of the things that um I think
has been missed in this conversation
today is that when a me when a member of
the fire service files a claim for
workman's comp it is typically denied
because they have the responsibility
that the employer has a responsibility
to act on that claim within 21 days so
what we're seeing is that some of these
significant uh health issues that are
members are facing
PTSD cancer Heart and Lung cannot be
diagnosed they cannot find out whether
or not those are job related within
those 21 days so they're being denied
therefore the member has to then go on
their own sick vacation time as um
brother llant had mentioned in his
testimony the problem is is that they
run out of that time what happens then
what happens when they run out of that
time and they have no more time to stay
at home and get better to come back to
work
the state of New Hampshire doesn't have
any laws that protect an employer from
being terminated in this case so
therefore the state their their employer
May terminate that employee and now when
they're terminated they're out of health
health insurance Senate Bill 350 is to
reduce that risk it it is to allow that
individual the 18 months that they may
need to while they're in the process of
filing appeal for their claim to cover
themselves and as has been mentioned
numerous times today
not have to drain their savings account
for health insurance for what is
possibly a jobrated
incident so for a lot of those facts
that's why I'm here today and to support
Senate Bill 350 and I urge the committee
to do the same and I appreciate your
time and I'm here to answer any
questions representative Rudy thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you for your
testimony um you been around a while how
often do you see something like this
happen do you have any idea on an
average a year or two years I well I
mean it depends on the type of claim
right I I see them denying claims on a
regular basis um as um chairman
infantine had mentioned earlier the
cancer presumptive has only been a
couple of years so we're now we're now
just seeing that kind of ramp up and
seeing more and more of those cases um
unfortunately it's probably about 50/50
split as far as whether or not they're
being denied at the first level or being
accepted thank
you thank you for your question no I I
was referring to the number of cases but
you the number of cases I I don't have
that number I'm sorry thank you my
understanding there was one case brought
it was denied and we amended the law
afterwards because of that denial
because it was kind of a ineter that's
my recollection
but correct extended the age that's
right all right see no other questions
thank you very much thank you I have one
last card
here
Albert
Albert I I don't have a card for you sir
sorry it's a Danielle Albert my
apologies for my terrible handwriting
that's what I thought want to make sure
Danielle um I'm Danielle Albert I'm the
Deputy Commissioner for the New
Hampshire Department of Labor um I know
it's been a long afternoon so I'll be
incredibly brief um the department does
not take a position on this bill we're
neither in support of the bill nor
opposed to it we would note that we have
reviewed the language we understand it
stated intent we believe we can regulate
it as it's written um and I'm available
for any questions should anybody have
any
you recognize thank you for taking my
question and it relates to um an injury
compensable injury and whether or not
you can be discharged from work because
my understanding is and we passed
legislation which guarantees should
job I think it's a little bit of a new
question there's not anything um
outright specific in the workers
compensation statute that says employers
are barred from discharging employees
who have been injured there are certain
instances under the comp statute uh
where certain employer type benefits can
be triggered reinstatement to employment
temporary alternative Duty uh where an
employee can assert said benefits but
that's a post compensability
determination um you're not going to be
eligible for those benefits unless
unless you have a determination on on
compensability in which an employer is
going to need to either take back Andor
provide alternative work options for an
injured employee those would not apply
at the stages that are conceptualized by
this proposed language that was a lot
sorry just quick question I get injured
yep I'm going through the process yep I
thought that under the the provisions of
the current
law I'm I'm working along I'm getting
better the employer can't just fire me
for work for comp that's not the case
it's not specifically outlined in the
workers
compensation statute at 281a in do you
know what if I'm not remembering the
provision can you point me towards it or
um I mean I think to to take action
against an employee who has asserted
their right to file a claim um you know
I'm I'm a to make a very sort of a a
basic description I'm mad at you I
didn't want you to file a workers's comp
claim I wanted you to do something else
might fall under the Whistleblower
protection statutes um that would be
somewhat different analysis um but I
don't think I'm and if you point me
towards the section if I'm not
remembering off the top of my head I'm
I'm happy to take a closer look at that
and amend my
answer representative seaworth thank you
Mr chairman um if you could help me
understand how the existing law Works a
worker is injured on the job the
treatment is clear but there's a
question as to whether the injury was
job related so there's a denial there's
an appeal
process what happens in terms of workers
comp and that treatment in the meantime
right
now also a very good question um and I
think it's a a question of what options
are available and I believe attorney OK
Conor is behind me he might have some
better Insight outside of the workers
compensation context as to what um
options are utilized by employees in
these scenarios if an injured worker
makes a claim for injury that is you
know there's a specific time frame
employers are required to file the first
report simultaneously notify their
insurance carrier that triggers a 21-day
review period for the insurance carrier
to investigate and do whatever they need
to do to make a determination are we
going to voluntarily accept this claim
because we agree it meets the standard
of um arose out of and in the course of
employment or are we denying it because
we don't believe it rises to that level
it's not a compensable claim they have
21 days in which to do that um within
that 21-day period they are supposed to
if they're not going to voluntarily pick
up the claim um issue a memo of denial
which I think is what's contemplated
here um so in those instances where a
claim has been denied the Worker's
Compensation Insurance carrier at that
juncture is not on the hook so to speak
they're not liable for the provision of
those medical benefits if going through
the appeal process employee petitions
for hearing hearing at the department
maybe they're dissatisfied with the uh
initial hearing they take it up to the
compensation appeals board or further
whatever that trajectory may be if
they're down those appeal lines there's
a determination of compensability then
there are ways to have the insurance the
workers comp insurance carrier go back
and either pay those bills if they
remain outstanding or there's some stuff
that happens behind the scenes of a
health insurance provider a regular
health insurance provider um paid on the
paid on the bills um and and I again
that's a process that I'm not well
versed in because it's somewhat outside
the kind of Realm of what the department
is regulating um so I think it kind of
depends um I don't think that employees
are barred or precluded from trying to
put it through health insurance whether
or not health insurance is going to take
it if they think it's workers
compensation related is a different
question um so I'm not sure if that
fully answered your question I'm happy
to try to clarify no that does thank you
very much I think you are correct they
do have to help insurance does have to
accept they will then put a lean on any
workers's compensation claim that should
then subsequently be accepted and they
will get reimbursed from that that's
normally the way it works and that
process of how that reimbursement
happens is not one the department is
typically involved with unless some kind
of problem arises that gets brought to
our
attention
right any final questions
Daniel all right thank you very much
thank you
Mr
oconor Welcome to The Price is Right
okay good afternoon everyone Mr chairman
thank you for allowing me to testify
this morning so my name is Jared oconor
I'm an attorney with Shaheen and Gordon
um I'm here in support of the bill um
I'm really here to just answer any
questions I can um I've been practicing
workers compensation exclusively for
about 20 years it's all I do is
represent Injured Workers at the
Department of Labor so I'm very familiar
with how these cases work um rather than
give you a long spiel I can answer um
representative McKenzie's question first
the answer is employers can and
absolutely do separate people from
employment if their claim has been
denied then there is no valid workers
comp claim just yet so the employer
doesn't have any obligations to the
employee other than those that exist
under federal law for example like under
the FMLA if the person is injured they
have to take leave they can take their
12 weeks assuming they've been there
long enough um but after that 12we
period of job protection expires the
employer can administratively terminate
them while the claim is pending and then
if the claimant goes through the process
of litigation you have your first level
hearing at the department you have your
appeal and then you win then the
claimant can assert the right to be
reinstated if they're able to return to
work and at that point they can go back
but in the meantime the answer is no um
they don't have to pay anything and with
regard to your question representative
seaworth as was indicated you're correct
in that while the claim is denied in the
initial stages the claimant cannot
submit the medical bills to the comp
carrier and expect them to be paid
because they've taken the position this
isn't related so they don't pay for
anything because of that the claim it in
most cases as a practical matter can
submit ongoing treatment bills to their
private health insurance carrier um
sometimes there's some resistance from
the Private health insurance carrier
because the records indicate this is a
work-related condition and so they push
back
usually as a practical matter we can as
Council push back on the carrier and say
look the comp claim has been denied you
are responsible in the first instance
and then at the end of the case we get
to the end of the case and we lose and
it's determined this is not and never
was work rated health insurance
privately should have been paying the
whole time anyway but if you win then
the providers all along the way can
resubmit those bills to the comp carrier
and everyone gets reimbursed um which I
think also addresses some of the
questions about cost because
particularly for self-insured like the
city of Manchester City of Nashua for
workers comp if they're paying out of
pocket for treatment pending the outcome
of a workers's compensation claim should
the claim be deemed compensable U then
the workers's comp carrier well the
carrier will reimburse any municipality
uh for anything that they've paid out of
pocket for any medical bills um is there
any other questions that I can answer
for the committee regarding procedure or
how these cases look on the on the
ground for taking my thank you for
taking my
question so this
bill will fill in the Gap and eliminate
these problems yes yes that's the idea
it'll eliminate the problems
CL not that this directly addresses your
question but more broadly the the
universe of claimants that we're talking
about here the class of people to whom
this applies is really small I mean it's
defined as strictly the emergency
response Public Safety workers with
presumptive conditions and there's only
two presumptive statutes that we have in
workers comp one is for PTSD for First
Responders generally and the other is
heart lung and cancer in firefighters
and so I want to say how many active
firefighters are there full-time in the
state of New Hampshire I believe the
number is something like 3,000 or less
um I
personally I like I say I only represent
claimant Sy the full-time my full-time
practice it's all I do as workers comp I
probably have currently 180 active
clients this bill would affect two of
them that I can think of off the top of
my head um it it's not something that
happens very often but when it happens
it is devastating um so that's the idea
is to try to address that
inequity I have a question I may have
confused myself when I was um asking
Senator sus a question on lines 1112 and
13 the employee shall be aable for this
benefit starting at the beginning of his
or her employment and for a 20 a period
of 20 years the effective date that
means they can up to 20 years from the
date of they they they're starting their
or excuse
me uh 20 years from separation
separation they can make a claim under
the workers's compensation correct okay
correct it's not saying they're getting
the the workers compensation benefits if
they do survive if they they are found
eligible for 20 years correct yeah if
you've been out that long um the the
only benefit you would be entitled to at
that point would be medical it wouldn't
be Indemnity but this this statute
addresses nothing has no effect on
doesn't provide any additional Indemnity
benefits it's strictly related to the
provision of maintaining the health
insurance so you want to make sure that
if there's a separation someone retired
at 55 years of age comes a legislator
and um something
happens and he's uh hasn't been a
firefighter for 18 years right
this is not going to happen to this guy
because he's tough but you know you get
some kind of lung cancer or something
like that then it shows up then he can
still apply for that workers's
compensation under this policy correct
yeah but and under existing law too
under existing law you can still apply
what this does is help provide that
health insurance coverage pending a
denied
claim I'm confused again okay
was that my fault well I I don't know
it's my fault um you said it would
provide health insurance coverage this
person has been out of work or out of
firefighting work for 18 years who's
going to still have employer-based
health insurance very few people
although it it is my understanding and
actually there's some others that might
be able to speak to this better but it
is my understanding that some
municipalities um do provide that when a
retire when a firefighter goes out on a
accidental disability retirement like a
work rated disability they have the
option of continuing to either make
payments on and maintain the health
insurance that they have with the
employer um or it's just provided by the
employer in perpetuity follow up follow
up but we're not talking about somebody
who went out of work on a disability
we're talking about somebody who simply
retired no no no if they're I'm sorry no
if they if they go out of work on an
accidental disability retirement that's
a term of art that means have a work
rated disability that precludes your
return to employment so for example if
you are diag if you're a 44y old
diagnosed with stage four lung cancer um
and I have a client like this uh whose
claim has been
denied uh you can be litigating the
workers's comp claim applying for The
Accidental disability retirement uh and
then at the end of the workers comp case
if it's determined that this is in fact
work-related then the retirement system
will also deem that as accidental and
then qualify them for benefits going
follow up again yes follow
the I'm talking about somebody who
simply retires okay yep has been retired
for 18 years and suddenly develops one
of these um cancers that is covered um
it doesn't seem to fit under this
section because that P person seems to
be unlikely to still have employer-based
health insurance I think you're right I
think in that circumstance that person
doesn't qualify for they can't maintain
an employer provided health benefit that
doesn't exist okay so like I said before
probably wouldn't happen but does no
harm I think that's right
okay representative McKenzie a
question the current law allows an
employee to maintain their uh
participate in the uh employees health
insurance even after they're retired so
they could be retired for a number of
years that's the case in in that's the
state of La actually so so there you go
that that's yeah that's certainly
possible I don't qualify for Medicare
right avalani thank you Mr chairman um
thank you for taking the question um so
the testimony was for a current worker
that is
under an appeals process for a
claim in your in your line of work how
long does that usually take if there's a
lot of back and forth back and forth
back and forth is it 18 months 24 months
could it be a number of years it it
ordinarily is not a number of years 18
months tends to be the outside um so as
was indicated you file the workers's
comp claim you report the injury or the
disease the condition the carrier or the
employer has 21 days to say yes or no
once they do that then the claimant has
18 months to request a hearing usually
you don't want to wait that long to do
so because again the clock is running no
money's coming in you have no health
insurance um so you request a hearing
when you do that the labor department
will schedule a hearing generally within
about six weeks so it happens quickly
it's the benefit of an administrative
hearing system so you have a hearing
within six weeks you get a decision
within 30 days of that at that point
whoever is unhappy with that initial
decision can appeal it and then you go
to the appeals board within the labor
department or The Next Step Up from the
labor department for your final hearing
that usually happens 5 to six months
after that and then you get your final
order so the whole process if everything
moves quickly takes less than a year if
it takes a little longer and sometimes
in cases like these they can take a
little longer because cases of whether
it's heart disease or cancer they take
more time to develop the record they're
more complex medically so people need to
hire experts but even then it's
generally still done within less than 18
months and I guess I should say if it
takes longer than 18 months this statute
caps the benefit anyway I mean there's
an explicit limitation that this is only
payable for a maximum of 18 months once
claimed so that's the question I have
should it be until should it be longer
no should it be worded that until the
claim is
adjudicated I mean you know that's
entirely up to the up to the committee I
suppose um I would say in the for the
most part the 18 months is enough to
cover U while the litigation winds its
way through the system you know you can
imagine like anything in the law you can
imagine unusual circumstances where
something gets pushed and continued and
bumped and then someone has an appeal to
the Supreme Court and it gets remanded
and it takes forever but that's really
really unusual I mean the whole point of
the workers compensation system as we've
designed it here in New Hampshire is
that it doesn't go through the superior
court process it's done administratively
at the Department of Labor so that it is
informal fast and you get quick relief
thank you which is nice which is nice it
it really is but but I will say and I
don't know if I don't think I believe I
mentioned this but one other thing to
keep in mind and why this affects people
the way it does is that when you first
have the claim that's denied and you
request a hearing even if you get that
hearing quickly and you're at the labor
department within 6 weeks and you get a
decision that says yes this is related
if the employer appeals it all that
first level favorable decision gives you
is weekly Indemnity benefits the medical
benefits still are not payable even when
you win until the case is absolutely
final when you end up going to appeal so
you can have these circumstances where
someone's been diagnosed with cancer
cancer heart disease whatever you have
your hearing and are successful person
has some money coming in now so they can
keep the lights on but the medical
Provisions are not in place until the
case is over so this would address that
kind of inequity as well
okay anything
else thank you
ind6
and my my view was there's only a couple
of cases number one and you're probably
not going to get a couple every year so
they're few and far between however if
if this comes up and somebody's got a
couple of
kids why deny a a child health insurance
benefits
that can be
tough right
no um we we all have to come back back
together to exec anyways we've got four
bills to exec it's not going to take a
long time whether it's three or four um
if we just put this off until the the
other ones then um uh representative Bui
can continue thinking on
it does that have to be in
today okay have
okay so if we if I put an amendment on
and we hear it again in two weeks exed
in two
weeks Mr chairman is it so so the idea
of uh asking
for passage as presented is that out of
order at this point could I move the
passage of that U legislation we just
heard the the the rule the rule is that
the ranking member has to agree so um
it's not up to uh any any member to make
the choice
I Ru no it's a rule it's a
rule there's no rush as far as I can
tell well I have decided no
Amendment he
decided um I'm fine I'm
fine sure go ahead we we can knock it
off
I'm
open session
you recognize speak to your Mo I think
we heard some terrific testimony today I
think it's a it's an appropriate bill I
think it helps the veterans in the state
of New Hampshire and I'm proud to uh to
move the support of this legislation in
the passage of this legislation Mr
chairman call
okay forgive me uh if I mess up which
Republicans are here or not um Vice
chair seaworth
yes rep balani yes rep love is not here
rep kcom yes rep drgo yes ranking Dem
Sullivan yes rep buudy yes rep kahill
yes rep D sylvestro
yes rep Susi yes rep bushard yes R
McKenzie yes clerk votes yes rep Clair
yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes that's 15
to zero I to pass any objection consent
agenda or
because
outl so he knew it was going to be an
easy day
thank you Mr chairman given the
um great discussion we had here today um
there doesn't seem to be any change any
need to change this bill as it's
written to pass as we move in second
we've had discussion Madam cler if you
please call the r
Vice chair seaworth yes rep avalani yes
rep kcom yes rep drgo yes ranking D
Sullivan yes rep barudi yes rep
Cahill yes rep D sylvestro yes rep Susi
yes rep bashard yes R McKenzie yes the
clerk votes yes rep Clair yes rep stab
yes Mr chair yes 15 to
zero any objection to
consent um quick question Who on the
previous Bill yes who Mo made the motion
and who seconded representative McKenzie
followed by
avalani thank you
bring it back next year
this is
off
e
e e